e
good
morning
um nice to see everybody I'm I'm sorry
it delayed a little bit but uh I had to
go and get the gavel with this uh with
this group I I feel I need a gavel at
all
so um we'll start out our busy day with
uh the Pledge of
Allegiance representative Cornell would
you like to lead us I pledge alance to
the flag the United States of America to
thank you very much uh so this morning
we have uh a number of bills to vote on
um on the docket and we'll get right to
that uh and uh there two off the top
that I'd like to talk about um I think
arrive um she she's presenting in um
um yes Mr chairman I just want to um I
received some comments based on our
hearing on Monday that I just wanted to
convey to the public some people reached
out to me expressing concern about
members not being present at all times
during hearings and I just want to
reiterate that sometimes because of
schedules people can't be at hearings I
know I myself missed hearing a week ago
um and we do our best to be here for
everything but given our salary of $100
a year um uh before expenses and and
other things um sometimes not being
present in person is unavoidable but we
fortunately have the ability also to
watch on YouTube um and watch the
replays or to listen in um as hearings
are being held and so I just want to
reiterate for the public that although
we may not be physically in a room that
doesn't mean we don't care about issues
obviously it's our goal to be here at
all times if we're able yes thank you
for mentioning that yes and just
remember that some people have been sick
and have sick kids I I am I am
painfully uh resident
Freeman thank you Mr chair as a person
who was not able to attend physically
the hearing on Monday secondary to viral
pneumonia um I would like everyone in
this room to know that I watch every
single minute of that hearing on YouTube
and I I I really did find the comments
that went out on Twitter um egregious
and and close to hateful because no one
misses a hearing because they don't want
to hear what any constituent in the
state has to say if they miss a hearing
there's a very good reason so I I I
thank you representative for bringing
this up and bringing this to light
because this is not the type of rhetoric
we need right now so again I thank you
for that thank you so uh the first bill
that we'll bring up this morning is uh
415 which is uh removing requirements
that schools provide menstrual products
and uh call on representative Lichfield
for a motion yes I'd like to make the
motion of itl please on House Bill 4115
I'll second okay we have a first and
second representative litfield would you
like to comment on your
motion I would thank you um although we
are not in the business of supporting
unfunded mandates this has been on the
books since 2019 I think probably maybe
it should not have been passed in the
first place but as one of the members
astutely put it we have hundreds of
unfunded mandates on the book so maybe
we need to take a look at all of the
other unfunded mandates at this point in
time um but as it looks now it looks as
things are going well districts some of
them even put in six figures to put this
in place at the time um but it's in
place now it's working well and we have
not heard any complaints out of any of
the districts so at this point in time I
think we should just leave it as
is thank you
um who made the motion
second you second representative Freeman
right thank you Mr chair I I I couldn't
have said it any better than what um
representative Lichfield had stated it's
been an unfunded mandate for several
years um if the districts are are are
cranking along with it and they don't
have a problem with an unfunded mandate
at this point I think we have big a fish
to
fry thank you any further comments
representative selig thank you I I would
um agree that we should it all this bill
but for different reasons I don't view
this as an unfunded mandate I view
menstrual products as essential as
toilet paper as essential as paper
towels as uh someone who has had the
misfortune of experiencing menstrual
symptoms uh unexpectedly I think that we
need to make sure that we're providing
sanitary um waste products for anyone
who needs
them thank you any further comments
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman C I would like to just speak a
moment of this that I did in
2019 this particular bill um and I I
appreciate representative L Field's uh
Point um
impacts the most needy
women in our state and they go back and
take that opportunity away knowing the
knowing the additional cost just costs
the youngsters not being in
school um it's not even a comparison so
I appreciate the fact that uh it was was
itl thank
you thank you any further comments
representative litfield if I may just
for a moment go down a 30 second rabbit
hole that being said these products are
not covered by Wick or EBT so when
you're donating at your local food
products see no further comments um
Madam chair Madam chair
uh here no thank you
um uh oh no order yeah um when the clerk
is
ready motion is I L Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative Nao yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall
yes representative B bony is hear okay I
can't see from here okay uh
representative Cel yes representative
kuger yes representative rung yes and
chairman cordelli yes 17 y zero nay
right and sorry I was remissed but we
welcome representative rang uh to our
group this morning thank you for joining
us thank you I consent um consent is
everybody okay with that great thank you
very much let me sign
it and
um uh representative litfield um if uh
you could possibly get us a um report on
that um as soon as possible so we can
get it in for the calendar for next
week tell the truth Chair by 1 pm
yes thank
you uh next we'll uh bring up uh House
Bill 388
which is uh issuing public reports on
special
education um and I'll turn the gavl over
Noble do you want to use it do I want to
use it yeah I'mma open the executive
session on HB
388 and I Look to representative
cordelli for a motion uh thank you I
would move uh itl on House Bill 388 I'll
second
good uh representative Corell uh I'm
sorry representative cordelli do you
have discussion uh yes thank you um I I
uh uh agree with the uh intent in terms
of transparency and making information
um
available uh I think that um this bill
um has some issues with regard to small
districts Pro uh student
privacy um I think some of the uh
information requested um possibly goes a
little bit too
far um we do have another bill uh HB 557
related to uh information that's being
made available um that we can always
amend if people want to um add some uh
special information special education
information we could do it on on that
bill um so that's uh why I U Move in
legislate representative Cornell I I
agree with what representative cordelli
said the
um the possibility of students um
records becoming or being identified is
concer especially in in small districts
um
and that that alone would keep me from
voting for it so thank you any other
discussion seeing
none Madam clerk you got it right H you
got it right I got a
what oh wor no
start all
right uh motion is itl Chairman Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative selig yes representative
kuger yes representative rung yes and
and chairman cardelli
Nays is that 170 yes 170 correct
consent uh consent everybody
yeah um and I'll try and get my report
[Music]
she
okay we're just checking a couple of
things here
okay so move forward with
that next we'll take up uh House Bill
730 um providing information on
adoption and
um rep Vice chairman Noble um the gavel
yours we open the executive session on
HB 730 requiring school districts to
educate and provide information of
students regarding adoption during
health education for grades 9 through 12
and in college in certain circumstances
and I recognize representative cordelli
for a
motion uh yes I would like to move uh
itl on House Bill
7:30 do we have a second representative
Freeman any discussion representative
um uh
uh adoption is a very important topic to
me as uh I was adopted from an orphanage
at a few months old in New York
City and uh two years later my parents
took me back down to that
orphanage um they said sorry no returns
just
kidding
um uh they took me back down to that
orphanage and I actually picked out my
sister from that orphanage
so this is an important topic to
me but I think that this bill is not the
right vehicle to address um the
topic um I think it's uh not necessary
to get the uh colleges and universities
involved um nor the Attorney General um
on this topic
um so that's um my reason for um making
the motion of vling um we have other um
other bills um
related um somewhat to this and I'm
looking at you know maybe uh amendments
to one of those bills to merge uh two or
three bills um so you know we'll talk
about that later but for now I itl on
7:30 any discussion from the
second which I can't even remember who
was
okay no thank you madam chair I I I
can't follow that can't can't follow
cordelli okay Madam clerk you discussion
oh I'm sorry anybody else have any
discussion sorry about
that okay now Madam
cler motion is
itl Chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative selig yes representative
kuger yes representative rang yes and
nay consent uh consent okay with
everybody thank
you um while we're waiting for uh
representative B bony to finish her
testimony in another committee um let's
start uh
discussion um on House Bill 671 we'll
wait for a motion until um the
representative returns um but um would
anyone like to open the discussion on
House Bill
671 represent Freeman would you like to
just discuss the Bill thank you um Mr
chair um I I naturally I'm leaning
towards this bill because at this
juncture we really need to have more
Tools in our tool walks to set our
youngest Learners up for success and
seeing as um this would address or at
least begin to open the conversation in
districts on how we can um begin the
process I I think this is probably one
of the least partisan bills we'll see
out of this committee so I I'm leaning
very heavily towards um aop
pass and would like to thank think that
um again this will demonstrate our
willingness to pull out all the stops
and to make sure that our youngest
Learners do have a solid foundation
pretty much like playbase kindergarten
when we passed it six years ago thank
you further discussion represent Murray
yes thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
clarify when you were saying districts
is it districts only um that have public
preschools or are you offering that for
all is that how you're interpreting the
bill I guess is what I wanted to make
sure that we were understanding because
it looks like it's the way the bill is
written it would be private preschools
as well as
public I think it says public preschool
providers is that I I believe so I even
um home home education as well okay
representative Cornell I I had questions
so I did get the phone number and called
Rob Riley yesterday and asked him a few
questions um I was concerned about um
data um release and people finding out
um and um I found that when families
sign up for it they they sign up knowing
that they're in explained that their
information is not going to be shared
only with the school district that they
will be entering if they want to they
can opt out of that um it's not
something that has to be in a classroom
some where or preschool individual
families can sign up for it I guess they
advertise a lot of places with a QR code
and families can do the QR code or some
other way and sign up for this um they
do get a computer um which is nice um I
asked about the 15 minutes actually
making a difference 5 days a week and he
gave me statistics on different places
that had used it where they tested
before and after and did show gains so
it made me much more comfortable with um
this I I'm not sure if if waterfood
would get the how that's going to work
but if it is them I'm all for
it um thank you I I view this really as
a a
partnership and I think you know
reaching um uh people in their homes
also I think is uh a nice aspect um to
this to this program um could I first um
before we have any more questions from
the committee see um uh Melissa white
from the Department here and um I was
wonder if you could come up I I just had
a question we had testimony about um a
grant grant funds that were used um uh
for this program um at one point and um
I was wonder if you
could uh Enlighten us more about about
that I'm Melissa white division director
for learner support at the Department of
Education so um fiscal year 22 and
fiscal year 23 we entered into a
contract with Waterford using our um
American Rescue plan sr3 funds so it was
the co relief funds that were utilized
for this contract to provide um the
early literacy services to families it
was 400 ,000 for fiscal year 22 which
only included part of fiscal year 22 and
then $600,000 for fiscal entire fiscal
year
23 fiscal year right uh do you know how
many um uh families or uh children were
able to participate in the program
during that period I do not have that
information they did Waterford did
provide reports to us I'd have to go
back and take a take a peek I was trying
to dig that up right when I was sitting
there um to have that information but um
I I can get that to the committee um
with the information you got um do you
feel that the uh program was successful
in terms of uh helping with Early
Childhood
literacy I think that would be difficult
to answer because there was no way for
us to measure that we couldn't do sort
of you know to measure something like
that you have to do some sort of a pre
pre-assessment and then a postassessment
and um for this particular population
there's no way for us to to have that
that data unfortunately thank you
represent Sally thank you um just one
when the person representing the company
that worked with us they referenced um
something to do with reaching out to the
AG's office um related to their Grant
and I wondered if you had any insight as
to why the Attorney General's office
would have been involved in a education
grant um because I didn't get I I didn't
process it until it was too late to ask
the question then that I'm not um
entirely sure of because the contract
was completed at the end of fiscal year
23 so that the and that was two like two
years ago um so I'm not exactly sure
what they reached out to the AG's office
about but I mean the AG does review and
approve and then our contracts go
through um you know governor and Council
so I'm not sure if it had something to
do with that component or but I can look
into that a little bit more to get
information thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question my other question
was around the data that you said you
did receive was that data that was
automatically sent to you or again did
parents have to opt in or opt out to to
give that data to you thank you for the
question no it it was actually part of
the invoicing process so Waterford would
collect information on the families that
they serve but it really was just um
kind of kind of a listing of of numbers
really of these are the people that are
served but it was all pii so we didn't
actually get information on the exact
like a name and uh address or anything
like that for the families that
participated I'm coming back question
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
when it says the Statewide nonprofit
digital programs and we're talking about
Waterford specifically is there a chance
it could be not Waterford are there
other programs that we know that are not
nonprofit Statewide you I mean or is
this really it doesn't state state
doesn't State Waterford but it probably
is that's a great question I think I
mean it it would be at the discretion of
this body I think that if we could do an
RFP and put out a request for proposals
to see if there are other organizations
at the time um during covid we were
looking specifically on increasing those
literacy outcomes and engaging those
families during covid that were at home
so they could better support um us their
families and in those you know three to
five year olds and pre-literate students
and so it was
um a soul Source contract that was was
done at that time but I mean we could do
an RFP however with a dollar allocation
if it were to pass I wouldn't be able to
do anything I couldn't do an RFP I
couldn't enter into a contract because
there would be no funds to do that
follow up yes so I I just want to make
sure here so if this were to pass as is
it probably would be Waterford so that
you wouldn't have to do an RFP and
whatnot I think because of the
procurement process that the state
requires I think we would have to
probably do an RFP um particularly with
the governor new governor and coun
executive counsel um they want to ensure
that the um procurement process that the
state has outlined and is in law is is
being followed I think at the time with
the emergency funds it it was an an eem
kind of fell into that emergency
category but seeing as we're out of that
um it would probably be best to be
following that procurement process and
and follow the competitive bidding
process I do one more followup sure so
are there other companies that we know
of or is it pretty much the not that I
know of but I mean I don't I'm not you
know the most knowledgeable I guess on
those uh early literacy program so I
mean we could do that request for
proposals and and see if there are
others
okay thank you yeah yeah it's my
understanding there would be you know
the normal procurement process yeah um
did I see another hand representative
Woodcock thank you chairman Kelli good
morning good morning welcome um I just
want to be clear the uh basically $1
million that deal we provide during
those two physical years for this
program during the co piece when they
presented the other day they also said
that they had a million 1 $5 million
Grant on the federal government that
went through UNH is that how did that
play in that one I'm not aware of but
the the grant uh the contract that I
oversaw or I should say the Department
of Education oversaw was the 1
million okay that came through the
division thank you um just going back
then to because there isn't um as you're
aware there isn't a financial note
really attached it just something coming
I'm looking at um the line eight on the
bill which talks
about subject to extent the funds
appropriated shall be uh provided for
preschools uh my concern
is knowing the physical climate we're in
right now that this would seem like a a
really good bill perhaps or a Feelgood
Bill and clearly Readiness Bill and
people would think that it's going to
happen but it doesn't appear to me that
that being the case in the only $1 in
the The Chill correct um would that be
your same take on that yes I would not
be if it passed I would not be able to
execute it with the dollar appropriation
we wouldn't be able to do anything last
last one just on that point um it it's
my understanding this would go to
finance and they would see um where
things stood with the budget um and uh
because there is an appropriation if
even a dollar in here they can uh amend
it uh to uh increase that appropriate
ation um and there's also um you know we
we talked about this being a public
nonprofit um partnership um so there are
uh nonprofit uh opportunities out there
also to contribute to this can I follow
up on your point you may follow up thank
you chairman um going back to your point
chairman and once again um I'm looking
at the
the I don't I don't have a problem with
the program I'm not a happy guy with
computer young sitting around reading
and the parents helping them but what
what does concern me is that the
limitation we put that whoever the
provider is they have to be spef be a
nonprofit a registered nonprofit based
on Bas 24 I understand the particular
vendor from before was uh and can be in
the future but I find it really
restrictive because I'm sure there are
many I'm guessing many I'm sure there
are for-profit companies out there that
provide similar services or comparable
Serv serves that won't be even eligible
to apply based on that nonprofit
definition
requirement is that how you read that
bill um I don't know how many would
apply but if we did an RFP we would
include the requirements in there so if
the nonprofit requirement was in statute
we would include that in the RFP have to
be enough okay thank you thank you
chairman repres Murray and then M
representative Terry after that thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so the I believe we did get a
late arriving fiscal note if that was
correct I I I do remember that um and it
did set up the appropriation funded at a
dollar but I think it was $600,000 was
an estimated cost for fiscal years 26 27
and 28 potentially it wasn't clear to me
if that was spread out across all three
fiscal years or if that is per fiscal
year but I it seems like it's maybe
spread out um thank you for the question
so that was based on what we paid for
fiscal year 23 fiscal year um 22 was
just a partial year so I based it on
fiscal year 23 because that was an
entire year that we had the contract so
it would be $600,000 per year based on
that previous contract but again I mean
we could do the RFP and then um see what
the proposals we've received and um came
in at okay follow if I'm right and then
in addition under the methodology it
does mention Wick um but I was curious
if this would also be available to
programs like starts and that type of
thing for for application or to share
with their their family base correct
that's my understanding as
well thank you very much uh
representative um Terry yeah um as it
turns out uh thank you representative
Woodcock for your um your last uh
question and concern um because I want
to Echo agreement um with that we I
believe we want to make sure
that um the best providers of these
Services would be made available um I
don't know you don't I believe you don't
know we don't know um the breakdown
between nonprofits and for-profit
providers uh nevertheless um I I came
away from the hearing on the bill with a
distinct impression that there was there
there were more than one uh nonprofit uh
provider
and so um I'm I'm hopeful that as we
move forward we will find that there
will be uh providers from other states
that are operating in other states that
would Express an interest so that uh
ultimately as I said we can end up with
um the best provider not only in terms
of dollars but um with respect to
evidence-based results in uh in other
you thank you thank you very much Miss
White for being here today um and I see
um Teresa Rosenberger in the audience um
there were a couple of other questions
and maybe uh you could help us with if
if you
wish
sure yeah yeah I I think one question
off the bat that I call was um if there
are other companies um out there who
might uh fit the criteria to uh to bid
in an RFP for this yes there are other
companies as I understand it nonprofit
and for-profit around the country that
that could qualify thank you additional
would may I answer uh rep C's question I
I did mention the AG um that was totally
different when because we had children
signed up and the money the contract was
over June 30th um we were looking for
what I call um out of the box clever
ways to serve these children we looked
at the op batement funds that the state
got because of the lawsuit a while back
and we realized that there were a number
of towns that had not used the funds and
when we looked at the guidelines I think
there were 177
guidelines it looked to us like one was
prevention of drug abuse and alcohol
abuse Etc and we were
interpreting and thought we had reason
to interpret that that having kids know
how to read and be ready to read and
learn to read by third grade might
actually prevent some of the drug abuse
and and alcohol abuse in teenagers Etc
so we went to the city of London da and
met with the city manager and the
finance gentleman who thought great idea
cuz they had up at abatement funds they
also only did half day kindergarten and
they thought we could provide the 15
minutes a day for the kids who in half
day kindergarten to keep them on track
and and be with other kids who whole day
kindergarten across the state they then
had to go to the Attorney General's
office to get approval to use their
opioid abatement funds for that purpose
that was what was turned down and so
therefore they couldn't do it because
they were they were totally on board as
we were so nothing to do with the um the
other contract and the contract that um
that um Melissa Miss White is speaking
about and I was speaking about were the
same because the the Ursa three funds
were the funds we got through UNH and I
think she's right it was a million a
million I may have said a million5 but
but I think she's right that it was a
million and we had gotten funds through
the United Way and Nashville before for
the pilot program which were not part of
the Ursa funds so I hope that Clair
clarifies that and happy to answer any
other questions if there are Murray yes
thank you for taking my question one of
the other questions I had was with
regard to I understood representative
Cornell um brought to light about the
techn techology itself would stay with
the family after they were finished it
doesn't necessarily get returned back
anywhere but what happens to the like
let's say if internet is connected do
they lose internet connectivity if it is
paid for through the company or how do
how does that work no the company the
company is I and I you know I haven't
asked that question recently to the
company but as I understand it the
technology stage in the internet now
once the child has I I well let me go
back and clarify that for you cuz I'm
not sure the family gets the internet
connection
forever I mean they
certainly Waterford certainly has paid
for the connection while the child is
using the program and the the equipment
stays with the child but I'm not sure
they pay for the
internet forever and and the reason it
was a private public partnership is as I
understand it the Department can't pay
for the
equipment well we couldn't they couldn't
use the federal funds for the equipment
so water for being a nonprofit came in
with with funding and and paid for the
equipment and the internet connection
but if you like I'll clarify that for
you I I'll I'll send rob a text when I
go back to my chair represent
Terry uh M Ros if I've heard you
correctly you've indicated in your
remarks that there are both nonprofits
and profit uh
entities uh Mr chairman if if that is
the
case um then I I don't believe that we
know why the sponsor chose to indicate
that on line
21 um e on page one of the bill that
kindergarten literacy Readiness program
is defined um as non profit and
nonprofit only so do we want to look at
the
possibility um of asking the question
why only nonprofit to the sponsor um so
that we might be made aware of why
there's a compelling reason that um this
would be limited only to nonprofits as
we might want possibly want to possibly
consider eliminating nonprofit to open
the field to all providers whether
nonprofit or profit
yes if you'd like to respond I think um
one of the reasons is in other states
where they've had public private funding
that that there has been Foundation
money that has helped supplement so for
example here if the state appropriates
let's say $600,000 a year that may not
cover all the cats who who sign up it
may it may not but if you you know if
you're if you've got kids that if you
got more kids then you have money then
you don't want to turn kids away and so
you may well go to a foundation to say
could you any up aund and half extra
$150,000 to the state and if so a lot of
times foundations prefer nonprofits to
for-profits and I think that that was
the reason to put it in there I know
when we were trying because as you know
we had kids signed up um for this
current school year that we can't fund
and so again we tried the foundation
route but what this bill does is it says
this is important to the state and in
many ways will allow foundations to go
we understand there's a revenue issue
here maybe we can help out in something
important so that I think is the reason
it was nonprofit okay follow on point
yes um so are you A Ware of uh other uh
nonprofit programs in other states such
that if this bill were to be enacted
there would be more than one entity or
provider potentially that would apply I
will double check again but when we were
talking about this originally there's no
question there were other entities that
could nonprofits that could qualify and
our and Waterford would hope it was an
RFP would hope you would put at RFP and
Miss White's right when they got the
contract originally it was during covid
and I think the state everybody the feds
every was trying to do everything they
could to keep kids get kids prepared and
keep them up to up to snuff but uh we
certainly would welcome it being a a
competitive bidding process and that we
certainly would expect there others that
would apply thank you thank you I'm
repres Cornell Thank you um when I was
speaking to Rob Riley yesterday I asked
him about that I said you know you you
help he said we did help write the bill
and we hope it would be us he said but
he did realize that it would be open to
others too so you know he they hoped
but representative
litfield thank you and thank you for
taking my question um I'm not sure if
I'm directing this you or the entire
Committee just a little bit of a
different standpoint on this my
understanding is that um many children
by third grade right they'll level out
whether it's half day for example or
full day kindergarten um kindergarten
was originally developed really to be
play-based and to socialize and these
days I think we're pushing kids further
and further to learn right addition
possibly subtraction in kindergarten and
reading um I feel or I'm wondering if
pushing this at a kindergarten level are
we pushing children to learn at a much
more rapid level that maybe they're not
necessarily ready for or you understand
what I'm saying I don't I don't know
isn't kind wasn't kindergarten
originally meant to be socializing and
now we're pushing these children further
and further I'm just concerned about
undo pressure with a reading program
such as this or literacy excuse me
that's a tough one to answer I have four
grandchildren and let me say it's very
different than it was in my day when I
was read when I was
educating and and uh supporting my kids
I think because it's 15 minutes and when
you actually look at the program it's
interactive and so I think what this
program is only trying to do is be a
supplement to either preschool or at
home play or at home learning Etc be a
supplement that just gets the kids so
they are ready to learn it's not teach
teaching them specifically to read but
it's teaching them the fundamentals it's
really called I think it's really the
science of reading it's really getting
them prepared so that when they go to
kindergarten they are they are they they
they're they're I guess the only word to
use is they're ready I mean I certainly
know I had a granddaughter who was
miserable because she went to
kindergarten and couldn't read and and
everybody else could and it was really
tough and I wish in this case we'd had
Waterford so she could have at least had
the the the the background um but but
it's it's meant to be 15 minutes 5 days
a week and it's really meant to be a
supplement so they are ready to read
they're excited and the results have
been have been positive for the kids and
I think if I remember correctly Rob told
you about and you can repeat it cuz I'm
getting it secondhand about a child who
did Waterford here and then went to
Massachusetts I hadn't heard that before
yeah and it sounded like the child was
ahead as far as ready to learn yeah what
selling thank you and this is more for
the committee but I just wanted to Echo
representative lichfield's concern about
pressures I think back to when I was
teaching kindergarten um granted 23
years 2
a lot of years ago May 34 years ago um
it was the late 1990s sorry um math
clearly is not my my forte and was not I
was an English teacher later and not a a
math teacher but you know my
kindergarteners came in we had a class
of 18 17 of them came in not reading um
17 of them went out reading and the one
child who didn't was our youngest
kindergartner barely uh was on the cusp
in terms of age appropriateness to go
into first grade the following year and
ultimately his parent because his school
district then opened a full day
kindergarten made the decision to have
him repeat kindergarten um and he was
reading within two months but he wasn't
ready you know he just wasn't
developmentally ready and I I I support
the concept of the bill I support the
idea of having additional Reading
Readiness and learning Readiness
programs I personally would rather
dedicate our money to Universal educ uh
preschool for all children because I
think that play-based interaction and
socialization is crucial and and through
those we develop the skills for
school-based Readiness um I'll support
the bill because I also think literacy
is crucial um but I wish that we could
dedicate money instead to programs like
in Maine when I I live on a Border Town
so my daughter was born in Maine and
they sent me home with a huge tote bag
full of books um from birth through
kindergarten age appropriate for me to
be able to share with my child with
followup about how to use those books
and I I wish we would consider I wish we
had the money and the resources to be
able to provide all of those things for
our families
instead thank you um see no further
questions thank you oh one more rep try
I'm sorry so can you just clear up this
is a voluntary program it's not like
everybody has to do it yes it's totally
a voluntary it's a it's a choice Pro
when I say choice is the parent chooses
to do it or the preschool chooses to do
it yes it is it is a choice it is it is
voluntary you're
welcome represent
question thank you Mr chair um I I I
want to stress I know it says it in here
anywh but literacy is not only reading
you know I watched some of the videos
from Waterford um they were not
stressful on kids but it was showing
them how to count but it was like
dancing and whatnot and yes it is
technology but um I think it can't hurt
right I mean it was it was math literacy
reading whatnot so um I I have to say
I'm in favor of this
you um seeing no further questions on
the bill um represent Freeman you had
talked about a motion earlier would you
like to actually make a motion at this
point since we have a full compliment of
our committee well yes thank you Mr
chair I would I would like to um move to
671 is there a second I'll second
represent Dy seconds represent Freeman
do you have any uh comments on your
motion thank you Mr chair um uh other
than the initial comments I made which
were a little while ago um I I find this
bill to be one of the the most positive
things we'll do in this committee is to
um begin to lay a positive POS
foundation for our youngest Learners and
um what I what I've seen of this program
um I believe that this is something that
all four and five year olds will Embrace
readily and given the 15 minutes that it
entails it won't be a long shot to keep
their attention so again I think this is
another tool in the toolbox for our
youngest Learners and I um
wholeheartedly support this thank you
repres try anything yeah I just want to
say I think we gave it a nice vetting
this morning and I'm I think I like the
way that we've answered all the
questions that I had about this Bill
thank you anything further from M
committee um Madame clerk when when
you're
ready the motion is OD to pass yes Vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
selig yes representative kuger yes
representative rung yes chairman
cordelli yes 18 Ys zero Nays uh one your
vote
sorry um yeah yes so the the vote is 18
y zero Nays thank you is consent okay
with with the fin yes okay
yep uh yeah just a$1 I think okay is
okay the clerk can yell at me later if
you wants can we
[Laughter]
watch uh I'll make sure it's uh live
streamed
thank you very
much um next we'll take up uh House Bill
571 uh related to Constitution Day and
patriotic exercises in
schools um representative McDonald I
move that this bill ought to pass thank
note um if I can find it uh there is an
amendment
Mr chair do you need a second on the
want to pass
motion he pardon do you need a second oh
I'm sorry yes I'd be happy to do so
you
um yes there is uh an
0090 um and I see I am uh a co-sponsor
of that Amendment
am not supportive of the amendment I'll
amendment if if no one moves the
amendment if no one on our committee
moves the amendment then we don't need
to take up the amendment do we right um
if if there is no one who would like to
make a motion actually or second a
motion on this amendment we can just um
proceed on with the original Bill if
that is agreeable to everybody there is
no second so um we'll just move to uh
pass
correct uh discussion on the ought to
motion Valerie would you like to comment
on your uh thank you Mr chair I decided
to move this bill a to pass because I
think it's important we recognize
Constitution Day and this bill does not
prescribe a curriculum and allows for
local control in how this should be
implemented evening the time that it
would take to implement this um and we
already do this for Memorial Day and for
Veterans Day but whereas Constitution
Day falls in September it really sets
the tone for the rest of the year in
terms of patriotism and really as
students as they grow to become
adolescents and to as adults even in
their rights and responsibilities as
Citizens to ensure that foundation so I
will move OTP and I would just like to
add to the record that there was a mixup
with OS but I was meant to be a
co-sponsor of this bill but for whatever
you um I'll speak to it
just uh I just want to Echo uh
representative uh McDonald's remarks in
support of um OT
and uh to to highlight the fact that
this this is the the foundational uh
document for our country and so that
it's absolutely imperative uh not only
that we U devote time in our schools to
the study of the document in the history
but I think it's just it's very
appropriate to uh make sure that we um
actually have a a Constitution Day I
think this is um this a great Bill thank
you uh if I'll just uh comment
um uh this bill actually is um the first
bill I submitted as a legislator back in
2012 um it passed the house something in
the order of 325 to
25 um but was killed in the senate for
unknown reasons um which often happens
in the Senate um and this bill as
presented um is amended based on what we
did in the house back then uh to um
include um recognition uh as well of the
New Hampshire Constitution um so that
we're we're talking about both because
this is talking about really Federal
Constitution Day which is September 17th
uh of each year so um I would love to
see um this bill finally become law um
even though oh I guess I am a co-sponsor
okay um I I made it but you didn't I'm
sorry representative McDonald um so is
there any further discussion on this
bill r s thank you I just want to point
out I forwarded to all the committee
this morning an email I received from a
kindergarten teacher um she called me to
ask about this and just wanted to point
out that it she didn't view the bill
bill as necessary she talked about how
in her kindergarten classes she Begins
the Year by teaching kids how to say the
Pledge of Allegiance and because she's
teaching them how to say it she spends a
lot of time explaining what it is and
how it works and she knows that that
process continues through the
kindergarten classes across the district
as well as the first and second grade
classes across the district because the
kids don't remember when they come back
what those things mean so they spend
that time in the element Early
Elementary years going through this
process and at our um upper school
levels we also incorporate civic
education which goes through the same
information and so it wasn't that there
was opposition to the concept it was
just that it's already being done and
that an additional mandate wasn't
necessary
so um I I'll just add that I I believe
it is um law based on legislation that
was passed several years ago about uh
explaining the uh pledge of allegiance
to classes um as well so I'm I'm very
happy to hear that uh something that
we've passed is uh actually being done
uh always good to know
bill uh Madam clerk this is ought to
pass on House Bill
571 Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray
yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Boni yes representative
selig um yes representative kuger yes
representative rung yes chairman
cordelli yes 18 Ys zero Nays can send is
okay great thank
you
um 500 consent that's
uh yeah
um I I'll mention um
699 is on um the list for
today um we have an amendment uh that
was put in by representative katab that
I believe we all have um however I put
in a subsequent
Amendment um that U included hers but I
added
um a few words to the definition of of
the brain injury as re requested um by
the New Hampshire Brain Injury
Association and also um we had
discussion about um related
Services um being uh crossed out
um um and um so I added that uh related
Services as per um the section of
Ida um that is
appropriate um that Amendment um is not
I keep checking is not ready yet um so
we will uh hold off on that until it's
ready which could be this afternoon at
lunchtime I'll check with alls and see
what happened to my Amendment but that
covers both yes rep thank you thank you
chairman so the initial Amendment you
spoke about is going to be rolled into
the one you created correct okay yeah
covers both I I don't know anyone else I
don't have the initial amendment I I
apologize for that's okay just can roll
in thank you
yeah Mr chair I just wanted to say that
um the amendment we got the amendment
the same day as the original
helps was
there was there another amendment to the
amendment there there was yes I I put in
an amendment to the katab amendment
um excuse me question yes um chairman
cortell I'm just curious in your um
crafting of the amendment there were a
lot of groups that were present uh that
had some opinions about how to make a
better Bill and to really clarify it I'm
wondering if those uh any of those
stakeholders that were here at that
meeting were consulted in your crafting
of the amendment
no um we've had a request for a five
minute um Break um and then we'll uh
tackle um HB uh
208 um with School nurses so um if we
could uh ask everyone we'll uh take a
five minute break for a
caucus and um the uh the Democrats are
free to use our office either office I
think is
available
for
e
okay I think we're um we're back in
session and the next bill we wanted to
take
208 and I'll turn the gavl over once
again to um our vice
chairman uh we'll open the executive
session on HB 208 and I recognize
representative Cordell for a motion uh
thank you I would move uh a to
pass and would then like to offer an
amendment as well do we have a second on
the a to pass a secondes oh oh I'm sorry
I not representative
you um I I representative litfield did
did you have an amendment that you
the amendment is uh
338 and um just simply this bill allows
the superintendent and School Board to
nominate and appoint a school nurse who
must be licensed and registered with the
Board of Nursing so at this point in
time we receive testimony from the
Department of Education that they're not
in the business of doing licensing for
nurses so they would prefer not to have
that responsibility it's not necessarily
appropriate are you are you entering a
motion on the I that
amendment representative so I I'm just
trying to understand why in the
amendment we would take out any
requirement for the person to have any
repres litfield sorry so we have a
nursing shortage at this point in time
so this is going to help us to fill that
need I don't know that they necessarily
need to have it it was too narrow of a
hole for people to fit into I don't
think they necessarily need pediatric to
be in the
schools representative Murray thank you
um Madam Vice chair chair sorry um so I
share a similar concern with Ard to um
the replace all um and eliminating some
of the requirements to ensure that we
have um somebody who is well versed in
the complex nature of students who come
into our doors even as as little ones um
we're seeing more and more medically
complex students um and I would want to
ensure that whomever is in that role is
well versed in whether it's GI tubes or
it's a fe a fever um that we're ensuring
that those types of things are are are
being enumerated within and I think the
previous statute had some of that in
there like representative celik had
mentioned representative
Freeman thank you madam chair I'd like
to point out to um my colleagues uh line
two that says have three years acute of
chronic care current experience with the
about the amendment am
oh I am so sorry please I apologize
profusely and I I don't know where my I
apologize
do representative litfield I just so
walk me through this so we have a school
nurse who's going to be a registered
professional nurse who is currently
licensed what what would make her not
qualified to take care of the school
population
you you're not going to have someone
specialized in absolutely everything
represent Murray thank you madam chair
um to that end I think that um
representative Freeman started to talk
about the acute and chronic care
training there are other training
modalities for individuals who are
medically complex those children go to
our schools and are in our school
communities and so I would want to make
sure that that was there STI ulated
somewhere and this this amendment as
proposed is a replace
all representative
litfield so just going back to we always
go back to local control right if these
are very specific situations so if that
were to happen within any school
district within that population wouldn't
it be up to whether it be the building
principal or the superintendent to
ensure that that particular nurse is
well versed in what is happening
wouldn't they just wouldn't they
naturally do that in order to take care
of the
population represent Murray um thank you
madam chair and and I I share the same
concern yet again uh to the sponsor of
the amendment's position that if the
district is not in the or the State
Department of Education is not in the
business of providing a lure for nursing
and so therefore removed that component
we would want to make sure that
somewhere within the state statute we
are enumerating chronic and acute care
as being a modality that our nurses have
experienced
on representative Freeman thank you
madam chair and um before I misspoke um
a little background on me I spent 35
years um as an occupational therapist
and had an opportunity to work with many
many nurses and the Very things that um
representative Murray is concerned about
are the very things that these nurses
are so intimately trained trained on
from day one of their nursing experience
um additionally I would say that um
there would be a criteria based on what
the superintendent and the district
would need as far as nurses go and it
would be their decision if a nurse did
meet the qualifications you're always
going to come up on instances where a
child is admitted who has complex
medical needs and that would be the
district's responsibility to fill that
need instead of hamstringing them and
having a school nurse so I would support
this amendment again I I did speak out
of turn initially I did not see the
amendment I'm just catching up to speed
um but I we we need to loosen the
shackles on these school districts they
need to have School nurses and um the
districts know what they need and they
will act in the most prudent and um uh
best interest of the students so I will
support this amendment as well as this
bill representative
wock thank you mam chair I I just want
to be clear um for those of us that have
their book with them which is not me I
brought mine um the the uh if I
understand this representative so the
entire
229 uh which would be the first
paragraph This Hall colon colon one
would be removed and replaced with the
I don't yeah I'm not sure if he heard
you or not yeah I think she said yes
yes representative cordelli uh thank you
um we've gone around and around and
around with School nurses for multiple
terms um and as I recall the um last
bill uh like this um we had testimony
that um one the department um is really
not um they don't consider themselves
some themselves qualified uh to certify
uh nurses um but also the fact that
there is a cost in involved the
retirement cost a retirement cost in the
district goes up uh for anyone who's
certified um so there would be a
lessening of of cost to the district um
without that
certification and uh I don't see that
the certification by the Department of
Education um really provides anything um
to the process um that can't be uh
vetted out in uh the school hiring
process
representative s oh okay representative
Murray um thank you madam chair so I I
just want to be clear because we're
discussing the deletion of the entirety
and replacing of 200 colon 29 and on
section
four on it's page 822 it says all School
nurses hired after August 25th 2019
holding an associates degree in nursing
shall be enrolled in a
registered nurse to Bachelor science and
nursing program shall complete a program
within six years of the higher date that
removed Paul thank you madam
chair uh so is it also being removed in
the
original the
original um no I believe we
being amended there were only a few
small
sections representative Bon I don't know
if um the original Bill only
uh the the proposed bill um actually
only uh is appr applies to certain
sections um as you can see on 229 there
there's a whole list of qualifications
that School nurses uh uh should have um
and I'm just looking here at the
testimony from um the chair of the New
Hampshire school Nurses
Association and they were they were
supportive of making having
legislation um that makes it easier for
um for nurses to get
certification in fact it says the school
Nurses Association strongly supports
certification and supports legislation
that makes certification accessible to
nurses who are committed to practicing
in schools um this bill takes all that
away so I I I'm wondering did you ask or
has this been um ploted by the New
Association the amendment that we asking
about the amendment um yes I'm sorry the
representative lal's Amendment I'm
wondering if you have reached out to the
the New Hampshire school Nurses
Association to get feedback on this one
I have not I just sat through their
hearing
represent thank you again I just keep
coming back to not requiring or um in or
at least a preference for people with
pediatric experience I think about
especially at the elementary level so
many of our youngest children Express
things that are not actually medical
needs but as medical issues they might
be feeling anxiety they might be feeling
other areas and it gets expressed as
stomach aches or headaches or other
kinds of seemingly physical ailments
that are ultimately really what they
need as a hug and
reassurance and I
I am concerned that someone who maybe
only has experience as an anesthesiology
nurse which is a very specific and
specified training requires I think it's
four years of additional training Beyond
a ba and nursing or someone who's only
ever worked with patients in uh an
elderly care facility who then says well
you know I I can retire from that and go
work as a school nurse but has no no
practical or relational experience with
children yes they might be able to
handle broken bones and they may be able
to handle bloody knees but without
having had any training at all in
Pediatrics or experience
or someone who's this would make someone
who's you know graduated a week ago
eligible and I'm not sure if that's what
children representative
dry thank you I think this is when the
local school district would examine that
and make a decision as to whether this
was a appropriate person to be a school
nurse representative Morse uh just a
quick comment with the shortage of
nurses that we have throughout the
entire State I would rather have this
pass and have a certified licensed
teacher or school nurse sorry um in our
schools than to not have one at all
because they can't find someone who
definitions it's just my take
representative Hall so I'm definitely
against the amendment but I'm curious if
you folks like representative lville to
say do you see
the original Bill do you see that as
watering down the certification you know
watering making it e do you see the
original Bill making it easier to hire
School
nurses I don't know if I would if I
would say the word easier but um but yes
I think we are enabling lo I I think
we're enabling local control and I'm so
confused about I understand what you're
saying but we're not going to hire a
no because that's for the parents so in
my opinion the principal the
superintendent the people at the local
level they are going to know what best
suits their school every school
Community is different and I trust that
they're not going to pick someone that's
school represent Freeman thank you madam
chair I have to say I'm a little
surprised listening to my colleagues
talk about nurses like they just don't
know what they're doing or that they
would even risk their license by taking
something on that they didn't understand
or had knowledge of they are they are
licensed as heavily as as therapists as
doctors and they're not going to risk
their license on a case or a situation
where they could um be held liable so
I'm a little surprised um to hear the
lack of confidence in our nurses overall
and school nurse and a school nurse is
school excuse me well hold on what is
the point of order the point of order is
youing motive to the membership over on
this side as not caring about nurses
that is inappropriate I I I I disagree
I'm not ascribing I'm not ascribing to
any side I'm I'm merely making a comment
about a comment that was made I am not
I'm not attacking anyone or going after
any side I was just very surprised to
hear the lack of confidence in our
school nurses Maybe want to express it
that you have confidence in our school
nurses I have a huge amount of
confidence in our school nurses as well
as the administration that hires those
School nurses thank
you uh repesent
run thank you um I know I'm just a sub
today but um we voted on a bill to
mandate patriotic education during for
constitutional day and yet we don't want
to mandate standards for School nurses
so I just want to to point out it that
seems a little hypocritical for me if
anything we should care about making
sure that the people that are providing
Health Care to our children meet uh
qualifications thank you representative
s thank you I just I just want to go
back it's our the School nurses that I
have encountered both in my years as a
teacher as well as in my years as a
parent we have outstanding School nurses
who have training in working with
children and they are very different
than the people who I've interacted with
in medical settings when I have gone
with my parents to Medical um
appointments who've worked with them and
the types of questions the way they
phrase things and how they interact are
different that's not to say they're not
qualified that's not to say I don't have
confidence in their ability to handle
certain medical situations I I can't get
behind this amendment because I feel
like it Waters down the bill too much
and takes out many things I don't think
that people have to have both a nursing
certification and a license sure
necessarily from the state but I do
think they need to have a nursing
license that specifies experience and
and training with a pediatric population
because I do think I think about you
know some of the experiences my own
children had with the nurses and the
level of complexity that involved and
the ability to understand the
developmental stage of children
and how they express themselves and that
is unique and different from how we talk
about people with people in Elder Care
that's unique and different from how we
talk with our gynecologists or our
urologists it's different it's a
different level of nursing that's why
people have different trainings and
certifications as nurses I don't think
people are going to be giving up their
certification to do something they're
not qualified for but I worry that the
especially the language of this
amendment Waters it down too far and so
I I can't support the amendment because
it feels to me like we're saying well
you know okay you're certified to teach
High School history you could certainly
cover teaching kindergarten having
taught both the high school and middle
school level there's a reason I had two
different
certifications representative Hall thank
you madam chair I just want to go on the
record saying I do respect School nurses
and have fought hard for them um in my
40-year career thank you
vote uh we're going to vote on
Amendment ought to pass on Amendment you
go don't have the
number this is on the
amendment Amendment
um chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock
absolutely not representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
selig no Representative kuger no
representative run no chairman cordelli
move on to the otpa motion M Clerk or do
we want to discuss okay I think I need
to go yeah I'll move
otpa with Amendment
H do we have a second I'll second that
representative Freeman
seconds did you want to disc anymore
okay nothing further nothing further
we'll go right to the vote M clerk
otpa Chairman Noel yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative cig no
Representative kuger no representative
rung no and chairman cordelli yes 10
who is
itl thank
you okay
next give me a minute y um I I think
there was one more bill we wanted to
take up that was not on the list but um
I
believe are
calendar for the day says we can take up
um additional
bills
um yeah right um right and I believe
there's agreement to take up a house
bill uh
283 which we heard the other day um it
was a lengthy testimony hopefully the uh
debate won't be as lengthy uh
today on the bill
um and um I'll uh look for a motion on
283 and hold on one second while the
clerk uh gets paperwork together okay
number 2
right
representative thank you Mr
chair I'd like to
uh bring this to uh the attention
of the committee to itl this um relative
to the list of subjects comprised of
adequate
education
um because of hold on one second we need
a second
first uh second by representative
Woodcock uh yes you'd like to speak to
your motion yes thank you um although I
I I don't care for the language in here
as far as cutting back on
education our kids uh need the education
and I see crossover into different
subjects where uh it does all interact
together at some point
um as far as this bill I don't it does
not help our students but I just want to
say for the Civil lining that I believe
that it does bring to the Forefront of
the failures that our kids are seeing
and we need to shine the light on that
and find out why this is
happening
uh thank you representative Woodcock any
comment thank you chairman quelli um
this particular Bill annihilates public
education in its total and the failures
that the representative brought forward
in terms of predicating this on TES
School
clearly it depends which test you happen
to take but I think this totally
diminishes opportunity for students and
public education in New Hampshire by not
having an adequate background at all
this is not a minimum educ this is worse
than minimum education this is almost no
education and I highly support the itl
thank
you rep
s thank you Mr chair um so I have two
separate points the first is yesterday
um this bill was discussed at the
Holocaust and genocide education
Commission meeting um at at and they
asked me to express that um as a
commission and I abstained from the vote
just to make sure that I was keeping my
roles separate in that regard just to be
clear but uh aside from my vote it was
unanimous to oppose this bill because of
the removal of genocide education which
is part of a previous mandate that that
is included in our students curriculum
on a separate note from that I want to
make sure we're recognizing the 30,000
people who signed in in opposition to
this bill um sure we can all spend seven
or eight weeks reading through every
single one of the testimonies um as well
as all of the people who came to testify
in person um as well as the
superintendent of the school district
who um was it was implied that he had
requested this bill and he came and very
specifically said to us that that had
not been what he had requested he was
requesting additional funding I think if
we want to recognize how best to support
our students we need to be looking to
the committee that is currently meeting
down the hall and at the ways in which
we fund and balance education across the
state for equity and parity for all of
our students but this bill I believe
should be uh not not just ital if it
were up to me I would indefinitely
postpone it and remove it
forever representive Hall thank you Mr
chair um I'd like to respond to The
Shining Shining Light on our failures um
when we look at and we hear that a lot
um when we look at test scores which you
like to look at the N scores we're in
the top I saw three I've heard five so
let's say top five in the country so I
think we should stop shedding so much
light on these failures and and focus on
successes thank
you I'll just uh comment that uh I
understand the intent of the the prime
sponsor um I do think we need to focus
on the
basics
um the prime sponsor indicated that the
intent was to do that and then have
local
districts provide all the additional
instruction that they saw appropriate um
and needed in their District as um we
always hear about local
control um but um that often uh um uh
waffles in the wind sometimes local
control um so I understand the uh the
intent um but I do not think that this
was the um the right vehicle or timing
um for this legislation so um I will uh
be voting also for the itl motion
is there any further
discussion representative litfield thank
you Mr chairman so I agree that this
bill should be it uh I agree that it's
not appropriate that being said though I
do want to say I understand on some
level even though maybe he didn't do it
in the best way I understand where the
sponsor is coming from because yes we
are in the top five in the country or
even our local districts we could say oh
we're top 10 in the state or whatever
what concerns me is when we look at
those we're not saying oh we're this out
of 100% it's we're looking at it like
let's say oh the average across the
country is 50% I don't know what it is
but 50% proficient or 52% proficient so
you know what I'm saying if we if we
come in with those scores then oh we're
number one or we're number two that's
still not good enough for our kids like
I feel like we have to do better but I I
absolutely agree that we need to keep
the Arts in there because that's the
further comment representative Woodcock
thank you and I just want to close after
after my second that additionally every
youngster that come to public education
needs something to stimulate them if we
take out art music if we take out World
languages we take out Civics anything
that's going interest what we need is to
be sure that that youngster comes back
to school the next day motivated to
learn something and if we run these
people against the wall with three
subjects we are totally diminishing what
adequate totally educated youngsters in
New Hampshire they need the opportunity
to explore thank you represent
Morris I just want to make a comment I'm
pretty sure most of everyone in this
room knows that my district sits at 14%
proficiencies 14 I mean that's that's
really really really low um so I know
that for my district we need to focus
definitely more on the curriculum and
the core subjects before adding on
additionals um though I I do agree with
needing arts and physical education and
social study Civics and all those things
including photography like half the kids
that become photographers wouldn't be
photographers without Photography in
high school um and I I agree with local
control giving this back to the district
so they can offer these as electives um
but I trust in the school districts to
do what's right when they have the tools
that are given to
them thank you uh R NATO thank you Mr
chair uh I just want to address thank
you for saying that we need to make it
interesting for our kids to come to
school cuz if it's not fun not
interesting they're not going to go any
further uh absolutely thank you and uh
my district uh and I can look it up at
the Department of Education website uh
my my District's 40% um in math and
science is that an acceptable uh
percentage rate to to can just leave no
kid behind I don't want to leave any kid
behind I want them to be better than 40
you know the district be more than 40%
efficient thank you say thank you uh
clerk the motion is
itl vice chairman Noble yes
representative
Terry uh yes on itl yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cig yes representative kuger yes
representative rung yes chairman
cordelli yes 18 y zero
Nos and I take it consent is okay with
everybody
great thank you very much um again I'm
still looking for uh the amendment to
House Bill 699 um it's still not
available I will check at lunchtime to
see what happened um I handed it in in
person um so uh I will check on that and
we can always take it up uh this
afternoon if we uh get copies uh in
time um other wise we are set to begin
um afternoon hearings at
1:00 and um one second before youour
yeah um just uh whoever has signed up
for reports um if you could get to them
right now we have the chance to get them
in um in the hopper for the calendar for
next week which would be very good uh
represent of Woodcock thank you my
question is re if we could could come
back earlier from lunch so that this
important bill 69 is not tacked on at
the end
as no no this is what is the executive
session my request is if you can come
back to say 12:45 hopefully with the
Amendments so we don't um get so backed
up to this Bill gets discussed with the
am right yeah I I have no impact the the
right I have no confidence that the
amendment will be ready by then um but I
I will be checking at lunchtime um and
uh we will okay take it up as as soon as
I can get the amendment and get copies
made if we're here if we're here thank
you right right otherwise um we will be
here next uh Tuesday and Wednesday and
uh uh we're just confirming uh the
schedule with our assistant uh for next
have we have have
see a room up the hall available for us
on
Tuesday um and uh we'll be back in this
room on Wednesday um but with the
holiday on um uh Monday um I I we needed
an extra day next week and I did not
want to have to um schedule anything for
vacation
week so with that um we'll see you at 1
you
yeah um it wasn't wasn't scheduled but
we took it up and so I infer from that
he not only wants to the committee to
take care of the disposition of the bill
but he wants he wants to get it to and
get it defeated as quickly as possible
so we can put as much distance distance
from
this
e
we going to open the hearing on HB
676 relative to the composition and
responsibilities of the parent and
education service provider advis
commission and establishing education
Freedom account impact and parent
satisfaction surveys and I recognize the
prime sponsor representative cordelli uh
thank you very much uh um chairman
Noble
[Laughter]
uh for the record Glenn cordelli
representing tonbo wolfboro and as in
the beautiful Lakes
Region and U this
bill um really came um from a
discussion uh last year I believe it was
or it might even been during the EFA
oversight committee uh
meetings and that pertains to the um
current uh provider advisory
commission um in current statute it
basically is um an optional meeting to
be called by the uh executive director
of children's scholarship
fund um who uh
until uh the discussion that we had on
this subject had not called a meeting um
and I believe has called a meeting since
then so I felt it appropriate to um uh
to do a little work on the advisory
commission and make it uh a mandatory
meeting
um and you'll see that um on page one in
the top half uh I revised the commission
to uh nine
members rather than the current seven
and indicated that five members would be
a quorum of the
committee um in addition um I believe
it's already the case where the um uh
the director of the scholarship fund um
is a n non non voting
chairperson um and also the commissioner
is a non- voting member of the
commission and uh I revised slightly the
uh duties of the uh commission and
indicated that it shall meet at least on
a quarterly basis and more often as
necessary um and slightly revised uh and
you'll see in 15 through uh 19 line
um the duties of the uh uh commission or
the C yeah the
commission and that the commission
should uh provide an annual report uh
each November uh beginning next
year uh so I think that that's um
important uh to uh have that as a
regular meeting and not leave it up to
one person's discretion whether to have
a meeting or not
I then
added uh two new
sections um and these new sections are
already in law for the tax credit
scholarship
program so I lifted the requirements
from um that program and put them also
in the EFA program thinking that they
made sense um if they were in the tax
credit scholarship program um that they
should also be in the EFA program
because I think it's useful information
and um questions have been uh coming up
on uh or in the uh EFA oversight
committee on some of these
topics and the first is an impact
survey um that is given to parents who
have a child leaving an EF leaving a a
public school for an education Freedom
account and um soliciting reasons for uh
why they are leaving the public school
for the EFA and any suggestions they
have as to um why they left but what
might have prevented them um from
leaving the second one is a parental Sur
a parental satisfaction survey and that
is on P h
2 um beginning in lines
three and it's again it's taken straight
from the tax credit scholarship program
and is uh to uh solicit uh information
from parents about their
satisfaction um with the
program and they have the ability to
strongly agree through strongly
disagree um on the survey and it
prescribed
three uh questions that uh are to be
included uh in the
survey and uh you'll see those on lines
14 and so
that I felt that that information would
be
useful uh to all of us um and it's
already in statute for the scholarship
program which
um if you're looking for it um it's
probably not in our books but it's RSA
G and so the last two sections are
straight from from that
program and I'd be glad to answer any
questions thank you very much any
questions representative wock thank you
uh Madam chairman
Qui just a question um on on page two uh
line five go uh wh why why administered
by the scholarship
organization it seems to be a the
commission is running if I write if I
read your P right oversight commission
this commission is going to be getting
the they they um the commission is
really focused more on education uh the
service providers okay rather than
necessarily um parental satisfaction or
anything like that but why have a
separate enti
of the scholarship organization running
the survey why would it be
doe well children's scholarship fund is
the administrator of the program uh just
as they are with the tax credit
scholarship program in both cases it's
the administrator of the program who's
doing the
survey so I wonder not that may have a
change perhaps but I wonder if you're
going to do it using that why wouldn't
you just say the the administration of
the program I'm thinking something
changes along I I I'm I'm
not yeah I got it scholarship
organization is meant to be a generic
term okay okay that makes sense all
right thank
you represent of
celik thank you um on page one in um
where it talks about in section two
where it talks about how they are
appointed it says the members shall be
appointed by the director of the
scholarship organization and serve at
the director's pleasure blah blah blah
um um I'm
curious if the goal of this as I
understand it is to be an advisory
commission looking at this the survey
why it would all be members appointed by
the head of this program um if they're
serving it at that person's pleasure
wouldn't they potentially be more likely
to only appoint people they believe are
feeling satisfaction and omit sort of
the broader perhaps there are a number
of people who are part of the program in
oneac capacity or another who are in
fact dissatisfied with it but wouldn't
be appointed because they were at odds
with the director of that program I just
it feels sort of like having the you
know the the fox
choosing so I'm just I'm trying to
understand what the motivation is right
this is for um this advisory uh
commission is really um to look at the
uh education service provider
population um and um as you see in a um
if there uh uh are
appeals um of an education service
provider um perhaps they have been um uh
excluded from the program for an a
reason they can appeal to this advisory
commission um but then in B also to uh
this group is to uh provide
recommendations for um
improvements um and also um uh look at
um the account expenses sometimes um if
payments are um slow to the getting to
the education service providers um that
would be feedback to this commission um
to look at uh you know ways to speed up
reimbursement and things like that right
but my question is more about why would
you have the person in charge of the
program be the person appointing the
council that's supposed to be judging
them
um they know um who the um the people
involved are um and that um that is
current law I have not changed that
aspect of
it representative Corell thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um I I'm I I think I see it but could
you just like maybe give an example of
so that we can differentiate between the
scholarship organization and educate
service providers cu I think there it's
two separate entities and it's the one
is doing the other right yes um thank
you um yeah the scholarship organization
children's scholarship fund is the name
of the organization that um has been
hired um to administer the program and
is referred to in um 194f as the
scholarship
organization um
the
um the
um if the second part of your question
I'm sorry what would be an example of
service provider yeah um it would be um
anyone from um a private school who uh
had uh EFA students um attending the
school to a tutor uh to um a local
bookstore anyone who's providing
services to
um EFA
students thank
you representative Hall Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question in this
survey would there be questions about
those that have afas and go back to
Public Schools do we want that
information or is it included in here at
all um uh it is not but um it it could
be um we do know that
um um that a small percentage and I
can't remember the percentage of EFA
students um have uh gone back to their
Public Schools um in some cases it's
they wanted to do high school back in
the public school um but um uh it does
not specifically um ask for uh
information from the parents as to um a
return to the public school and the
reason is not one of the mandated
questions as I really just lifted that
section from the um uh tax gr
scholarship program um and those
questions were um I think uh developed
by uh Department of Revenue
Administration when the program was put
together follow up is that our fault the
second question sure wait okay thank you
um could they do these surveys without
it being in the you know a law can they
could they just conduct surveys they
could yes yep um
yeah and I I had had some discussions
with them um about doing those surveys
um but um felt uh at this point um you
know um with questions about
accountability and so forth um it was
worthwhile to put it into the statute
thank you representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative cordelli for taking
my question so um one of the biggest
issues that we've heard on um this
committee is privacy is there anything
in these surveys that would um uh
compromise the privacy of an individual
student um I don't believe so the
surveys are filled out by the
parents um they're not um to be made um
public uh information um I'm sure
aggregate information um could be
provided but um not individual responses
thank you followup followup thank you
and um just out of curiosity will this
uh will this information um that the
surveys um a mass will that be provided
to the district that the child is
leaving
um that's not um mandated in the U
current um bill but um yeah there are
many things that can be done true thank
you represent Murray thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question I
wanted to make sure I was understanding
when you said service
organization are we talking about the
same entity that I believe the
Department of Education had said in
other circumstances wasn't required to
send all of their data back to the state
of New
Hampshire
um I'm not sure what you're referring to
um uh it could have been um in relation
to uh an audit that was going to take
that is taking
place um and that there was some um
request for information that really the
department did not have and was not
responsible for I think was um uh part
of the discussion follow up if I uh
thank you so I guess my question is does
this bill require the service
organization or service provider
organization to send this information or
the results back to the department uh
uh the the um the commission has to do
an annual
report um which goes it's on um lines 20
page thank
you representative Cornell Thank you
madam speaker one more question it a
it's given to the parents of students
who have exited a public school Under
the provisions of the chapter so they
already there and and receiving in right
it was I I believe the intent was to U
find out why children are leaving U
Public Schools um and I I think in the
future that uh uh might be useful
information to the public school and um
possibly should be uh provided um on an
aggregate basis to um Public
Schools representative Bon thank thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative Celli for taking my
question on lines uh the on page two
lines for all the way through the end
you're talking about the survey um these
questions are phrased in such a way that
that is very um leans one way or the
other obviously in a positive way um so
it's kind of they're leading questions
number one there subjective questions
obviously you're asking parents
to determine whether they've seen
measurable Improvement um and I'm not
sure what you're trying to get at when
you say my child would have been unable
to attend the school of his or her
choice without the educational Freedom
program unless that follows up with your
the last question which it says
excluding the education Freedom account
how much did you pay out of pocket for
your child to attend school this year
again I are you going to really be able
to get accurate information I mean it's
it's very
subjective
um I I would hope we could get accurate
information but um you know with surveys
um that's always a question um as we've
discussed about uh that in in other
circumstances um but uh again these were
the questions um that I believe were
made up by Dr with the scholarship
program and I just took the same ones
um uh and think in terms of um
measurable
Improvement um you know one of my points
is that um uh this program has a great
accountability measure in in parents and
this is really to survey parents uh to
see are you in fact seeing
Improvement representative
cik thank you very much and thank you
for taking my question and also my
previous one because I realized I forgot
that those statements previously this is
really a followup on representative
Cornell's question about the um students
who've left I think it was
representative Cornell about students
who've left the public school we know
there are a number of people who never
had any intention of attending public
schools at all who went into the EFA
program prior to any element of school
so they wouldn't have left a school um
would it not make sense to have a
question that asked in a a different way
what their MO whether they had an
intention of attending public school at
all because if they didn't then we're
directing I'm I'm trying to understand
how we capture that very sizable portion
of the EFA population that had never an
intention to attend public school um
yeah that that might be a valid question
add representative cck thank you thank
you on on the I'm going back to the the
membership of the committee the the
appointed by the the uh director schol
organization I think if if my internet
is correct here I was us the phone I the
internet that there's 10 counties in New
Hampshire I think that's accurate um at
least based on two minutes ago is there
any chance we could have one person from
each County delegation
I just and and I think some refer it to
the the the hen and the hen house or
chicken house or scoop or something one
of those old phrases I'm not young
enough to remember that stuff but in
either case the U it would seem to me
that I'm just concerned when as someone
has mentioned if you have the person who
is appoint if I was appointing a
committee to do a somewhat biased
response survey um and give it back to
me I surely would want to put people who
I think are going to be Pro my
organization or my committee or what it
happens to be so I think if the
delegation if each delegation had one
representative appointed by the
delegation they still have almost the
same number of folks um and then just
was right that's all just a different
way I just I just have concern I'm
concerned about the who direct i' rather
have the commissioner anybody else
director yeah I'm not sure if the
commissioner or the designate might know
you know who the f right
um yeah I'm not sure who else could do
it um but these are the members are
either
EFA um parents or service providers um I
think it' be best to have a good mix
because again they're they're not doing
the surveying um this commission is
actually just doing um the duties in A
and B on 5 through 19 15 through 19 I'm
sorry I missed that you're absolutely
correct I think wrong I was think it was
the General committee right hand out of
those thank you no no problem representa
Murray thank you madam chair in that
cohort of individuals that is charged
with uh the review process of the
results um is there a public school
representative Public School
representative reviewing the responses
reviewing the responses yes cuz it says
that the the group the commission shall
meet in person but from what I was
hearing initially it was a cohort of
individuals who seem to have similar
perspectives well yeah the commission
again is is just is parents and service
providers because they're not doing uh
the surveys which are outlined um
starting in section three on line 24 um
this the uh commission is totally
separate from
below any other
Hawkins uh thank you madam chair for the
recor Brian Hawkins representing na New
Hampshire today I think I was at most of
the uh uh education Freedom account uh
legislative oversight committee meetings
over the last few years and I just think
some context U is important because I
think there's uh I think this bill is a
missed opportunity uh to actually bring
some
additional
um uh accountability to the program um
so first um
you know I I think that it would be
valuable to have um the survey that was
mentioned earlier about people who are
coming back um well back in 2022 there
was a bill filed um a bipartisan Bill
filed uh in the house to do uh a survey
of uh students who had left their uh
public school and from what I recall the
testimony from some including the
scholarship organization was to oppose
that so uh I would urge you to look at
that 2022 bill I will look up the number
I apologize uh and partly why I handed
my card in a little late was I think it
was important that this has been looked
at before um uh the year following the
passage of the program because I think
it it did have some um important
information there the second thing I I
just want to say is um I think it's
important to put uh some more um
actionable teeth into the bill about uh
these uh meetings in the information
because part of the reason I think we're
here and the the legislative oversight
committee
uh that the legislative oversight
committee uh I think it was last summer
um discovered was the parent advisory
committee wasn't meeting you know this
is years into the program and they had
not yet met uh and the justification for
that was anecdotally we know that
parents are satisfied with the program
and um I is a little astounding but I
think um you know that was an obligation
to convene under the law and it wasn't
done and so um so that that is another
um issue so I urge you to look at that
as you're contemplating the language
around this bill um the other thing I'd
just say about the um M opportunity is I
don't think that uh the whether it's the
survey
or um the amendments to the current
statute for the parent advisory uh
commission uh replaces the fact that um
we don't have much achievement data or
any achievement data from this program
and that um
the uh it it's ENT you know essentially
uh left out in terms of
requirements uh from from the current
law and so we don't know how students
are doing um academically in this in
this program whether it's improving
whether it's not if the previous States
who had passed a similar program to ours
is any indication who did have some kind
of some kind of assessment work that's
required and published uh on an
aggregate basis I would be if I were the
legislature I'd be very troubled by that
because uh a lot of that data is is not
good um some of it is um very
much of it is um very concerning in
terms of uh students who switched to uh
a bachelor program and the results uh in
some of the states uh that we've talked
about here in this committee before when
we're talking about expanding the
program um that those uh those results
um were were uh as I said very
concerning so I'll close my uh testimony
there and happy to take any questions
can or come back with any ones that I
don't don't have the information before
me representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so um I I
understand your concerns about the
committee not meeting but would you not
agree that this bill would force that
committee to convene and finally give us
the information that we
need I don't think we should have had to
have passed another bill to ask them to
meet
um uh I I think I think by the end of
the uh to be fair I think by the end of
the oversight committee meeting there
the meetings had begun I don't know if
there's been anything published from
those um but I think more
importantly that this seems to be um one
of the one of the only Central uh
markers for this program in terms of how
students are doing and I I just as I
said I think it's a missed opportunity
to just make some tweet make some tweaks
to The Advisory commission having to do
with provider approval
um and not and not go further in terms
of uh looking at achievement and also
looking at the actual process that is
undergone when um the scholarship
organization is approving a
provider representative celik thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
I just want to clarify when you talk
about um specific achievement data um
using this as another opport an
opportunity to create access to specific
achievement data from the EFA program
would that be like the current
standardized test that we administer
within our public schools at certain
benchmark grades I think it's uh if I'm
remembering correctly it's 2 3rd fifth
8th and 11th grades that our students
take a variety of standardized tests is
is that the kind of thing you're talking
about or something else I just want to
make sure that I where where we could
get some Benchmark data yeah wellc
because there's not one option that's
required um I would imagine it's hard to
get any kind of aggregate data uh so you
know I think that is testing the one and
only thing that is going to tell you
where our student is I'm sure all the
Educators many of the Educators and on
this committee former Educators would
agree that that is not the only thing
but I think when we're talking about um
having some kind of understanding about
where the program is I mean Tennessee
just recently did a pilot program we
were talking about proficiency earlier
in in an earlier committee and and um
they did a pilot program in one of the
school districts in Tennessee with a
program and what they saw was uh uh a a
significant lag behind local public
schools on on um proficiency score so I
think not knowing and having any kind of
marker is worse than is is is
problematic uh especially because you
are investing an increasing amount of
money into this program uh I know that
Department gave the both these
committees the policy and administration
excuse me policy and administration
committee and the funding committee some
data on the program that it was going to
grow from 30 to 38 million I think by
the end of FY 26 and so this even if
there's no expansion done this year the
program is going to grow at in terms of
the as far as the forecast uh and so I
think this is a good time to for the
legislature to to really take a look at
what kind of um assess accountability uh
that is a part of this program so any
other
questions seeing none thank you Brian
appreciate
it would anyone else like to testify on
this okay we're going to close the
my
e
okay we'll uh get started with our next
bill which is House Bill
740 requiring the Department of
Education to maintain student records of
Chartered public school students and uh
the prime sponsor representative fellows
is here
welcome to the education policy
committee thank you Mr chair committee
members I came from just down the hall
the from the education funding committee
um so the purpose of the why I filed
this bill is because a couple of years
ago a charter school closed it was the
one that was here in conquered and um
there was a lot of confusion about how
to handle different aspects of their
closure and one of them was what to do
with the Student
Records so you may especially anybody
who's new um to this committee may not
know but there's been a statute in place
forever as far as I can tell that says
school districts now we start start out
with school districts because this
statute was in place more than a hundred
years ago and that's all we were dealing
with at that
time that school districts needed to
Main Ain permanent records about their
students and those records consisted of
um enrollment for every single day of
the year you know was the student there
or not there why they came into the
school did they did they um just enter
at kindergarten did they transfer from
another place and it had um other
information in those records and uh
later on
when most most people were graduating
from high school those the transcripts
of um the students courses and whether
or not they graduated from high school
were also part of the permanent records
in statute it's defined permanent
records it refers to the enrollment um I
didn't find anywhere where it mentioned
the high school transcript but it does
so um school districts I I school
districts as far as I know have never
closed there have been school districts
that have
Consolidated U to make a Cooperative
District but there's never been there
there is no municipality that has
students that doesn't have a school
district so there's always been a place
to keep those permanent
records and but when we have now we have
charter schools and if they're approved
by the school district then there's no
problem because the school district will
just keep those records but most of our
schools are approved by the state board
so it's really important that we make
sure that we maintain those records for
those Charter Schools um should they
close that um were approved by the state
board so that's the intent of this
record so a student who you know
graduates from a charter school and
couple years down the road the school
closes and the person that student
should be able to get a copy of their CL
transcript to you know verify that they
graduated from high school and it's
probably even more important now because
we have these dual
enrollments um so kids can be in high
school they can be certified with
different um trade jobs so we need to
have records of that information so
that's that's why um this bill is
here uh I did a lot of research um oh to
go let me give you some more history um
I started working at the Department of
Education in
1985 and retired in
2017 so when I first started um the
statutes in the um statutes under the
responsibility of the State Board of
Education um then and still does require
the State Board to give to school
districts every single year a form to
keep track of these permanent records
and since I was started in 1985 I
remember those records they were U
printed on very nice archival kinds of
paper so that they would last a long
time and
um because there was that form which I
don't know for sure but I'm guessing the
form was adopted by rules because I know
that's the process now for
forms um it was
identified what had to be kept for for
those records well when after about 10
10 or 12 years so we get into the 1990s
school districts started to use
computers to keep track of their
students so there were amendments to
statutes that said you know you can use
you don't have to use that paper
register the um State Department of
Education gave you you could keep track
on computer but you had to make sure
that you had at least one paper copy and
there there was never any repeal of the
requirement to keep the Student Records
either and and so now we find oursel in
a place
where that is no longer in
rules um there was some
deletions I gave you you have a piece of
paper that has some of the changes that
were
made um historically to this some of the
statutes
but you know not really requiring a
print out but they're still required the
school districts are still required to
um keep those
records and they have continued to do
that because in the school districts
they've got all they have the um
historical memory the institutional
memory that just kept them doing that
and so they're you know they may be in
they're not on paper anymore they maybe
they're I don't know what they're on but
they are keeping those records so we
need to make sure that charter schools
understand that they need to do the same
thing they need to keep those permanent
records and when a charter school
closes my bill proposes to have the
Department of Education be responsible
for those records and the reason that it
makes sense to have the department of
education do it is because there are
also statutes about colleges and though
public and private colleges if one goes
out of business then the State
Department of Education is responsible
for keeping those kinds of Records so
some somebody can verify that they did
get a college
degree so that's what this bill
does
I know we don't usually do show and tell
but this is what copy of what one of the
registers looks like that was able to
get one from the school district and
it's a remarkably similar to what it's
remarkably similar to what um the school
districts keep now in terms of of
information on a student there's um
every time a student moves from one
school to another there are records um
made indicating uh did they go out of
state did they transfer it to another
District um there's code for if a
student dies and that's why you take
them off the
register and um if they're expelled and
if they graduate if they transfer um to
the next grade if they're promoted or
not so all this pretty much all the same
things that we keep now um work kept
back then so I I did not put in the bill
what the elements of the student record
are because you could really think it's
a Department's job to do that and put
them in rules which is this would have
been a
rule but this just makes it clear that
the Student Records won't get lost for a
charter school that closes and these are
only the only the chartered schools that
are approved by the state
board good thank you very much represent
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for bringing this bill
forward I do have one question so in
regards to other types of data that a
charter school may have in the event of
its closure if it's coming from
ascending District does that then also
just reside at the department of Ed or
does it get also sent back to the the
sending school for services or related
services
um
so so up until
2007 there was the information that came
from school districts up to the state it
never was about an individual student it
was always how many you know how many
students you had in each grade or
whatever and but since then the records
that they keep now at the Department of
Education they don't have the detail of
um an individual student what days they
were present and what days they were
absent that that is in here and that
should be according to statute and and
precedent they should have as part of
their per permanent record they do have
all the transfer anything that has to do
with coming in or leaving the school
district and school you know they keep
track of what school and what district
whatever represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for coming forward um
with this bill I do have a question
about school AG children so if a child
of schools
closes and that school age child
transfers to a public school doesn't
that record follow them to the public
school
that I I don't think so I think
well I think that probably the last
school year school year if a if a
student was in one school for five years
and then they they left that school to
transfer to another one I think that
probably the record for the last year
would go with them because what they're
mostly interested in is like what grade
should we put this student in I don't
think they'd have all of that
information follow yes I'm just but I'm
not I'm not 100% sure that's and I
appreciate your honesty about that um so
my followup to that would be if they're
only looking for the last year then is
that not the practice right now on our
Public Schools or do they just keep all
of the records in perpetuity for I mean
oh so no so so in terms of the permanent
record if a student was in one school
one District let's say one district for
five years and then they move to another
district for five years the the um the
five years first five years worth of of
information stays with that school
district the records stay with the
school district for
follow so that doesn't all of that prior
five years doesn't get reported to the
doe it does get reported to the doe it
was reported to the Doe by that first
district that they were in then when the
student transfers to another town then
they go to a different school and that
new school district is reporting for
every year thank you I'm understanding
what you're saying representative
fellows that at the point I was trying
to make is if a child is leaving a CH
school and going to a public school I
would hope that all of the records are
Fallen that child that was the point I
was trying to make but thank you for
your honesty on this so just one thing
to make clear if don't this has nothing
to do with special ed records that I
wasn't
referral I'm just talking strictly a
regular students right we we do have a
uh two people from the Department here
also that could answer questions
represent
s thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question and also Welcome to
our visitors who are here from
leadership conquer
um we're glad they're able to join us
today but um so I think about you talked
about schools that close the charter
schools that closed and completely went
out of business so this would be a way
to ensure that someone who graduated
from a school if the school then shut
down for whatever reason I think one of
the CCO schools did that there's still a
way for them to access their information
through the state even where where like
right now someone who graduated from
Dober High School can reach back to
Dober High School in 50 years and get
their records this would be if they
attended you know red bottle school that
went out of business that in 50 years
they could reach out to the state and
say I went to red bottle school I need
proof of that yeah that's that's exactly
the purpose okay thank you so
much represent B Money uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um my question is just
regarding to uh record retentions in
general um I assume that in uh the r
says right now that charter schools are
required to keep these permanent
records um
someone at the Department of Education
told me that was not true Okay the
reason I asked that is I know we've been
told that unless it's specifically says
a charter school needs to do that it so
this could be an issue in itself and and
the other question that I had is um do
parents always have the right to request
these records from the institutions and
so say if my child was uh going to
school in Rye and I was going to move to
Northampton could I request all my
child's records from Ry to be sent to
Northampton and then Northampton would
have the responsibility of retaining
record
so
you a parent could ask a a school to
forward the permanent records to to
another school district but that's not a
requirement the permanent records belong
with the um where the student was at the
time that record was
recorded thank
you represent wock yes chairman good
afternoon repres Fells um the number of
child schools that failed if I recall is
very small so I think about six maybe
yeah so this is a very limited
bill
right well okay I I mean it's not like
we're not talking about 100 Schools
we're talking about a very small number
of schools
not suggesting is not valid I'm sesting
it's not like the huge issue I mean it's
the issue but the number that would be
impacted in terms of schools and doe are
small um probably the the doe could
probably respond better to that I would
add that um they're already the doe is
already required to maintain the Records
for college transcripts when a private
college closes so I I okay that's fine
thank you thank you
sh I seen no further questions thank you
very much
representative uh and next um we have
two representatives from the Department
thank you very much for being here and
um I think you've heard some of the
questions about uh records and
transferring and so forth maybe you
could uh help us out with a couple of
those so sure and I think some of the
questions um are relative to how a local
school district handles school records
and I do think there are a few
representatives from local school
districts that might be better um
prepared to talk about that than the
Department of Education um so and I
don't know if they filled out cards but
whatnot um
relative to the bill in general the
Department of Education thinks this is
probably um a best practice specifically
for closed schools um not only for um
chartered Public Schools but also likely
non-public schools um we do have
challenges with individuals um when
their schools have closed getting access
to their Student Records um and having
some sort of Statewide consistency and
practice would be helpful for
individuals um that attended these
institutions because oftentimes
especially high school transcripts are
needed for employment military service
um continuing education and whatnot and
so um we do have a fair number of people
that reach out to the department on a
fairly regular basis looking for these
types of trans transcripts tal has some
more information and he handles a lot of
the information that comes in right now
but just high level so the department of
education does already have this
function for um career schools and
Institution of higher educations that
close um and so when a institution of
higher education in the state of New
Hampshire closes they give all of the
records to the Department of Education
and we we do have a part-time employee
at the department that their job is to
issue transcripts and Student Records um
the Department's biggest challenge with
the way this bill is written right now
is realistically the resources to do
this request so for postsecondary
records the department has the authority
to charge $25 um a transcript that one
pays for the position and the work that
the position does in that person's time
it also pays for you know special
transcript papers and whatnot that's
used for issuing the transcripts and a
lot of times there's mailing expenses
because oftentimes with transcripts they
are mailed directly to um directly to an
institution or to um somebody might who
like might live out of state so there
are some costs that the department
occurs with this and so for the
postsecondary we already have a way of
doing that with with the the fee me ISM
there's times that an individual may
need 10 copies of a record um if they
are um if they're you know seeking
employment or or trying to go to college
or something like that so that it is a a
process that we follow um but with that
so I think T is going to kind of clarify
some additional kind of questions or
concerns we have with the way the leg
the legislation is and then we can kind
of talk through the
process awesome I'll try not to repeat
any of Caitlyn's comments um first off
um we do um
support the distinction between within
HB 740 with the distinction applying
only to State authorized Charter Schools
um not including the language uh
District approved Charter Schools um we
did however have objection uh to the
wording of uh provision of Student
Records being provided by the department
at no cost as Caitlyn mentioned the
department has existing practices that
support the provision of student records
and transcripts from closed career
schools and institutions of higher
education that um these are self-funded
through fees that are charged as Caitlyn
mentioned it's a nominal fee of
$25 um this fee covers all the time
effort printing postage required for
these certified uh transcripts for
consistency sake we would request that
the same fee uh structure be applied um
in this particular case um so that we
could allocate appropriate time and
resources uh within the department
additionally we would also request that
the department have rule making
Authority um
with this um for earlier clarification
just because I know there was some
discussion about existing practices with
records um I would mention that
RSA uh 194 B16 section 7 does address in
the event of voluntary or involuntary
dissolution of a Charter Public School
remaining Student Records maintained by
the charter school shall be forward to
the Department of Ed if all records
maintained um sorry having to do a
little scroll rolling maintained by the
charter school have not been forwarded
to the schools uh the students District
of residence um where this has created
some challenges is um essentially a
student leaves the closed Charter School
they've indicated they're going to go to
a district or in some cases a private
school uh or some cases home school but
if the district or excuse me if the
records are going to be forwarded
they're forwarded over we've had
situations
where the assumptions made the students
there records are done the school closed
and then four months later we're getting
a request for for records that we don't
have because they were under the list as
having transferred to a district
approved Charter and then suddenly we
have no ability to find resolution for
that situation so um this new law
appears to close that loophole because
we would essentially be getting copies
of all records so that in the event that
a district did not receive records we
would at least have something to be able
to help resolve the issue
um I think that's about it any
questions representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair and thank you both for
being here I appreciate the
clarification on a lot of these points
you did mention the at no cost element
which I did not pick up on before um are
you aware of any public high schools
that charge someone to receive their
transcript or is is that the case or are
they offered at no cost um I'm not sure
what the process is for public high
schools okay thank
you I would just add on that I I looked
up three just as I was heading out the
door the three that I looked up did
not
Rend and thank you for taking my
question if I remember in our
introductory I'm new to this committee
um and I could have been wrong I I
thought that there were no District
approved charters as of right now is
that true or is that my memory there are
currently not any okay follow up if I
may yes and in the event that a school
were to dissolve let's say and you had a
100 students there and you were asking
for the $25 that would be $2,500
potentially worth of Records requests
that could potentially come in if maybe
more um would it be incumbent upon the
closing board of directors to supply
those funds to you or would that be for
I guess going on your question so the
$25 the department um C for our current
process we charge when an individual
needs access to their records so often
times this is 10 11 15 years after
school has closed and somebody needs
those records so the closing school does
not pay for that right now we did have
two schools closed last year we were
fortunately able to work with them to
get the records for that but because of
kind of the the lack of clarity and and
kind of rules right now um the schools
had just worked with us and and provided
those records but we didn't necessarily
have a formal
process represent Woodcock no the
question is okay represent s thank you
and thank you for taking my question I
just want to make sure that I understood
part of your comment that you would
actually prefer if we amended this bill
not just to add a an appropriate fee for
the service of retrieval of transcripts
but also to increase the bill um related
to private schools that should close is
that correct so um yes because so we
have the exact same challenges that
we've just described relative to
chartered Public Schools exists for um
non-public schools when they close um so
um we and it's actually sometimes these
are even more challenging with
non-public schools for chartered Public
Schools chartered public schools are at
least required to give the Department of
Education rosters and student data in
the same form that a district public
school did so we can at least at times
you know at least verify an attendance
for somebody at a school for non-public
schools we don't have that information
at all um and so we do have you know a
fair number of people that reach out to
the Department of Education on a regular
basis looking for their transcripts um
somebody actually just reached out to
town not too long ago they were looking
for their transcripts from a school um
from the 1970s they had thought it was a
charter school but it we didn't have
Charter Schools back then um so it so I
think it's really the best practice for
New Hampshire residents or students um
if the if there's one consistent
practice going forward the other thing
that I didn't say either is so you may
have a charter school that's located and
conquered but you may have kids that are
coming from all over the place and it
may be hard for that student to know
where their records are transferred if
they were transferred to a resident
district and and whatnot so continuity
would be very helpful for
them pH thank you and and to the extent
that you have language around um the
collect of um records from I believe the
term was uh from private colleges and
from um um I forget the were technical
schools that that have closed could you
share that language with us of or what
RSA it is that specifically addresses
the um open open your teams the records
there hold on one second I my message it
to him earlier today when we were
preparing yes I just that would be very
helpful for us to have the specific
langage RSA uh
DKK and there are also rules that um go
with this but I don't know the rule
reference off of the top of my head
could you repeat that RSA number 292 292
required thank you so very
much and uh that uh 292 section um is
related to is it for higher education
yeah this is the existing law for higher
education so it says any institution of
higher education blah blah blah blah
goes on right okay thank you any rest Mr
representative Woodcock thank you follow
to my question from before what are the
number what number are we talking about
kayin we talk about five or 500 what we
talking about we've had 10 charter
schools closed in the existence of
charter schools the total enrollment of
those schools was 2300 kids now that
might not be 2300 unique kids I didn't
go through and count the actual sassad
numbers um associated with those kids
but I mean and as time goes on more
Charter Schools May close non-public
schools there's probably thousands of
them because those are um those probably
they have a longer history and those
close more thank you so much thank
you any further
questions see none thank you very much
Heather
Barker
y y got it now I see it I was just
confused I wasn't sure was it supposed
to be right on my side uh good afternoon
thank you for letting me speak today I
actually popped down for this um bill in
support of it from New Hampshire school
administrators
Association Heather Barker yep and I'm
the student services uh director there
at
nhsaa the main reason that I would
support this bill is because children
and families are protected when you have
something like this there's there's
having worked in conquer at the big
Middle School we had students who moved
back and forth between Charter Schools
or private schools or home education
back into the school sometimes moving
back and forth and when you don't have
those records it's very hard to
determine um how to place a student uh
what kind of courses for example they
have taken giving making sure that they
are getting credit for courses that they
have taken and earned um the credit for
those so having also worked with Charter
Schools they have um different practices
from one to the next which is all part
of why that's important when they have
their Charter designing how they're
going to do that but having somewhere or
some in this case the Department of
Education be the institution that
protects those records if such school
closes right becomes really important
for that child and family I you know I
hear what the department of EDS said
about um a fee I I get that in public
schools we typically don't charge a fee
um and that's probably because you're
not when you're thinking about higher
education it makes sense because you
need a record um of note that's actually
the
um formal record for the student and you
also have informal records so for
example a student and a parent could ask
for a copy of a record that's not a
formal record that's going to be stamped
to be used perhaps that fee is $5 some
some universities do that they have a
different weighted cost for the formal
one that's going to be used um when
someone's applying for a job or applying
to college or to go to another
institution and then there's the records
that the parent and child have access to
in this case I I'm not sure that would
be a new thing and I had really thought
about it but I wholeheartedly support
the idea that children and families have
the protection that some some
institution the state of New Hampshire
is going to be responsible for
protecting those records for those
children and families
so that's my take on
that thank you very much any questions
great thank you great see none thank you
very much and with that we'll close the
hearing on House Bill 740 and in a
e
um split the difference between the two
clocks on the wall and this is House
Bill
719 repealing the use of unused District
facilities by chartered public schools
and representative K is kahill is here
to present his Bill thank you for being
here thank you Mr chairman and if I may
have a just a moment of
indulgence up until 8:30 this morning I
didn't know this hearing was scheduled
today
and so this is this was done in haste
and there was a lot of other plans
changed and disruptions and things but I
went through looking through I was
looking through this because this is my
last bill and I hadn't noticed the
hearing and then I look through the
email and I see EPA notice and when I
saw that because there are so many
emails and so many bills I thought why
is the EPA telling me so I that's why I
didn't take note of it earlier and get
all ready and I I have requested that
EPA be
changed um but uh that was a while ago
so I'm not holding my breath um and just
to sympathize with you um the first bill
this afternoon was mine and I discovered
that about a half an hour before the
hearing so uh so welcome I'm glad you're
here thank you sir um so you'll recall a
few years ago uh there was a bill passed
that um said that if there was unused
space in a building or a building it
first dibs to would be to charart of
school and I think that that decision
really should be left to the people in
the community that built the school that
have had their you know their children
go to school there maybe their
grandchildren are there now and maybe
there's come a time when that building
is no longer needed or usable and maybe
they would like to see housing or a
community center or
some sort of other business that would
you know have a lot of employment for
the town and but if if they want to have
a charter school I think that's another
option but it shouldn't be a preference
that they have to get through per first
so that's what I was thinking when I
when I wrote this and I know I've
emailed this to the committee uh not
that long ago today but I I will read it
just you know I'm going to do a little
skimming you know but I will read it for
the benefit of the uh public so uh our
schools in addition to providing
education are centers of community where
children and parents form bonds some of
which last a lifetime it is not uncommon
for teachers to have the children of
their former students in their classroom
our school buildings provide several
generations with this grounding sense of
place and continuity the buildings
require maintenance and sometimes
renovation and expansion to meet the
needs of students in some cases a new
building is more cost effective another
kind of bond that comes into play here
is the one that residents approved in a
warrant article needed to fund the
project they committed to pay principal
and interest for 20 or 30 years using a
portion of their property tax so the
project could be completed they approved
a tax increase because it was in the
best interest of the families living in
the community they are invested in in
the event of a school build a school
building to be retired due to
replacement or consolidation shouldn't
the elected School Board Andor the
residents make the decision on the
future use of the building
they have paid for the construction
maintenance and later studies to
determine when renovation or new
construction were the best path what if
they feel the best use of the vacant
School building is for housing or for a
taxpaying business requiring first
refusal for a charter school that would
recruit students from outside the
community from any distance a parent was
willing to drive does nothing for the
town's residents the state should not
interfere in what is a local decision
best left to the residents and their
elected government bodies now I I did
paste in a couple of Articles here
examples you know a little Charter
history and I know there are wonderful
charter schools that are stable and and
doing a great job for the kids that
attend but there are other situations
one what I want to call your attention
to because it's it's about you know what
happens when a charter school moves and
I know you know schools in our our
regular traditional schools don't move
uh they may shut down you know but they
provide for another another alternative
in the district for their kids so uh I I
recall this incident that happened at in
Kingston where a um Great Bay Community
like the great great uh Great Bay
Charter or Sea Coast Charter I'm sorry
um yeah so the the people moved into
school in Kingston that was already in
tough shape such it so bad that the
people of Kingston This is
representative Wilders Town had had
decided not to put money into it and to
and to build another high school and so
uh they didn't need this building it was
in poor condition I didn't know what
they were thinking they would do with it
but a charter school came along and said
we' like to lease the building you know
until we find something else and you
know the building was in poor shape fire
and safety issues uh the kind of thing
that you know happens in public schools
and they had they they Del leased for a
while then they gave them an extension
and they said we need more time and
really the time the time was worried
about liability what would happen you in
the event that there something terrible
happened and somebody some of these kids
got hurt so they eventually declined to
renew the lease
and they went the the charter school
went looking for Alternatives they
looked at the vacant uh vo vocational
training center in stratum still vacant
by the way and uh that they they started
raising money for that and I remember
this particular thing in the paper about
a I think it was a second or third
grader whose grandmother gave her $500
for her birthday
and that little girl put $500 toward
that Char school because she wanted to
keep going to that school she loved the
school in the end um they they decided
the stratum wasn't going to work out it
was going to cost them too much to fix
or it was the price was too high they
found a spot in Dover and in this in
this article the Headmaster of the
charter school said I highlighted this
uh he said some parents would be unable
to continue sending their children to
the school because of the new location
but no matter where we moveed stratum or
do the distance was a big concern a lot
of our families are just not able to
make it but our overall goal is the
school
sustainability uh D dorso said the SE
Coast chart is going to be looking for
new families in the Dover and Rochester
area to join them now I wondered where
that left the the third grader who
willingly donated $500 I didn't know if
she was going to be making that Journey
twice a day uh I'm not sure which of the
many towns that were served by the
charter school in Kingston I'm not sure
how far her parents had to get her to
you know in order to be in do and
continue the schooling that she wanted
she may have in fact returned to the
Local District and her in her community
and often times they find that that
works just fine uh it might have been
better than they expected because maybe
they' never tried it or it might be that
they're they're learning new things and
with other kids that they can see in
their neighborhoods it's it's sometimes
really is a very good experience to get
on that yellow bus or or ride with your
parents or walk down to the street to
that local school that is such a big
part of your
community um the other one was about and
I'm afraid this this happens a bit more
a bit too often where a charter school
opens up and this was one in
exor
and it it was closing Le less than two
years after it opened and I as I recall
hearing that they had kids in tents and
using portal Nets in November while they
were still getting things together with
the with the facility and there was
there appears to be some sort of
financial fraud and mismanagement and I
know this has happened before in in
another school in conquered and there's
others that are
questionable and it's not a reliable
opportunity for the critical education
that we know our children need and
deserve uh I think you had some
testimony recently about how strongly
members of the public feel about their
public education the curriculum that
that's available to them in their
traditional Public Schools so uh I I
understand that there is a place for
Charters but not every place and I think
we've gone out of our way to promote
Alternatives when we have a a fine
educational system here in New Hampshire
could it be funded better you bet but
there is really is serving the public
serving the needs of the communities
where they're located and as I recall uh
uh commissioner edel blue and uh
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos uh
had $47 million with which to encourage
charter schools and I think another wave
of that is likely coming in the current
Administration
and this was as I recall there were 29
charter schools at that
time and there were according
commissioner edbl seven of them were
worthy of replication his his
description his his decision and I
wondered you know why didn't they spend
the money improving the other 22 schools
instead of expanding something that
isn't always the best could you suspend
for a minute yes you state your point
please
related to whether or not that's correct
if we could just stick to the bill
please uh yeah well I think it is
related because when we when we when we
take public
money and and and uh allow the transfer
whether whether it's uh whether it's for
building Aid which is the other Bill I'm
trying to do something about or allowing
the charter schools to come in and buy
uh or lease school you know a school
building I think it is I think these
question these stories are gerain this
is about you know the history that we
have with charter schools in New
Hampshire and if you look in the news
you'll see similar stories all across
the
country uh yes some of them are are fine
but not everyone and we need not uh make
sure this are Charter in every town or
uh that everyone has easy access to it
it's not necessarily the best and as I
also back later in the art in my piece
here I did look at the recent test
reading what order what what the test
scores have to do with this bill
education education is the central point
we can stick to the uh the closing of of
uh um build buildings um and unused
space we don't need to get into test
scores
um well I mean I I believe the idea
funding education and adequate education
is includes uh the curriculum the
building right we're we're not dealing
with funding of Education either oh
that's right this is the policy
committee yes and when the policy
committee you decide what schools get
funding and which ones don't or how much
perhaps no okay the bill is about the
bill is about allowing the community to
make their own decisions about what to
do with an unused school and I think I
made the point that it's a violation of
local control to have this bill in
effect and I urge you to vote to repeal
it all to pass on
719 thank you very much questions
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question representative this bill if I'm
correct seeks to repeal RSA
19461 which for reference is on page 631
of our books and continues on to page
632 and you also cited that that this
RSA this section of law violates local
control and doesn't give communities
options and I miss understanding the RSA
when it says that the school district if
it's not used for academic purposes
extracurricular activities
administrative school function Sports
and for which the school district has no
Schoolboard approved ridding plan for
future use that they can still use this
for whatever they deem if it fits into
one of those categories the last being
more of a catch-all any approved wring
plan so what am I misunderstanding that
this RSA violates local control when
there's four listed options thank you
for the question I believe it is the the
the part that I'm having trouble with is
that the school the local community is
not free to offer the buildings of just
anyone first refusal must go to a
charter school if a charter school is
interested they get first offer and then
the uh if there are competing offers the
commissioner elbl will step in and
correct additional questions
representative Freeman thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
coming in front of us so um do you do
you do you know how the districts um
dispose of unwanted buildings that they
have no further use
for uh thank you for the question I I
believe it is left it was at least left
to the uh school board and with public
with public uh input to decide whether
it would be uh housing or some other use
or sold to a charter school which has
which has happened before this
legislation was passed followup yes do
you know how many chter schools um have
put in office on unused school buildings
that the community has deemed is no
longer will fit their needs I don't know
thank you
further questions I see none oh I'm
sorry representative s thank thank
you
oh okay thank you sorry thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
I'm glad that the other bill was not in
place when our new Middle School was
built in my community when we had to
tear down the existing Middle School in
order as we flip flop buildings but I'm
I'm curious how the RSA around the
unused buildings and unused space is
impacted if if the building is as other
schools have been deemed unsafe for
continued use how does that impact the
sales of or the leasing of to any entity
if they don't want to sell it but they
really just want to eliminate the
building all together U let me see if I
can answer that I'm trying to understand
how that connects with all of
this let me see if I can answer that I
think if you have well the example uh in
in Kingston was they had an unused bill
building that was not attractive
apparently to investors at least at that
time uh things change right uh I'm aware
of a school in summersworth that looks
just like the one in New Market that
opened in
1925 uh that a developer repurposed into
housing just a few years ago um so you
know certainly an empty school is could
be used in a variety of ways and uh I I
think the communities generally want to
find it the best possible purpose for it
and it could be a charter of school or
it may be housing or it may be it may be
any other use but I think it should be
left to the community they shouldn't be
dictated to have first refusal for one
or the
other quick followup okay thank you very
much so my question is more it's not
about repurposing a building but what
happens as a case happened in Oyster
River where the previous Middle School
needed to be torn down they literally
flipped fields and the school locations
but also because the previous building
was no longer functional as
yeah I I think it's possible it's
possible with in line of the other bill
that that added made them uh made
Charters eligible for building Aid it's
possible that a charter school might
apply for the building Aid and get State
money again uh to bring the bring the
building up to some level of safety I'm
not sure if they have the same standards
as the traditional Public Schools I
would hope they
did representative
Murray I'm sorry yes representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you and
thank you for taking my question so um
the idea of a unsafe building not
withstanding um this bill this section
of law just took effect in 2023 given
that Charter schools and school
buildings don't open up every few months
um we haven't really had time to test
this much and given that charter schools
are public schools doesn't it seem like
the best place for them to start to look
for buildings is in public buildings
public school buildings uh thank you for
the question I I I don't disagree that a
school building would be probably a very
good use for a another type of school or
or school I my point is that I think it
should not be an automatic first refusal
for a charter and I know many of them
set up in shopping malls storefronts and
you know uh I would like to see them at
the school myself but if if that if
that's the will of the community that's
I think that's
fine R Marie thank you Mr chair and I
guess to representative dr's Point um
regarding there not being a whole lot of
time that we have had around this the
way I am interpreting this section of
the RSA is that the district has to sort
of fish for or look for Charter Schools
whether through an RFP or it says
pursuant to paragraph one a school
district shall offer an unused facility
to a Charter Public School and so my
question is does that happen through an
RFP process if a building is deemed no
longer usable through the district or is
that something that they're literally
do they have a public comment period of
time where a charter comes forward and
says yes I'm interested and then that
closes and if there's no interest it
opens up to something else uh I'm I'm
not sure because again it may not have
really happened yet but my understanding
is the schools are required to notify
the
commissioner uh when they have schools
School space that's available not not
with not a plan for use and I imagine
the commissioner makes that list
available to those who want to open the
charter school I'm not sure if he's
reaching out to housing developers in
the same
email we do also have several people
from the Department
here great thank you I see no further
questions thank you very much for
hello thank you hi um I'll begin by
reading my statement and then I have a
few points based on some of his comments
um yeah could if you could just uh
introduce yourself and your organization
that you're representing yeah um thank
you for the opportunity to provide
testimony today my name is Jody Adams
and I serve as the executive director
for the New Hampshire Alliance for
public charter schools uh I'm here to
express my opposition to HB 79
which would repeal the right of the
first refusal for charter schools to
access unused districts um school
buildings across 22 States similar first
wrer refusal laws recognize the
importance of making vacant or
underutilized public school facilities
available to public charter schools
these policies reflect a broader
consensus that all public school
students should benefit from taxpayer
funded assets regardless of whether they
attend a traditional District school or
public charter school the V majority of
students attending public charter
schools come from the very communities
in which these schools are
located they are local public school
students and deserve Equity access to
facilities that their families tax
dollars have helped fund denying Charter
Schools the ability to use vacant public
school buildings are not only
inequitable but also undermines the
intent of these spaces to educate our
children furthermore when District
school buildings sit empty or
underutilized it represents a glaring
inefficiency in the use of public
resources allowing charter schools to
use these facilities ensures the
taxpayer dollars are directed towards
educating rather than allowing buildings
to deteriorate or remain vacant this is
fiscally responsible approach that
maximizes the value of public assets for
educational
purposes unlike Traditional School
District Schools Charter Schools do not
receive direct funding for facilities
instead they must secure and pay for
spaces using operating budgets often at
Market rates this significantly reduces
the funding available for instruction
teacher salaries and student programs
providing access to unused District
buildings helps level the playing field
and ensure that Charter Schools can
allocate more resources to their core
educational
Mission moreover uh shared use of public
school buildings can foster
collaboration between Charter and
district schools by working together in
shared spaces both types of schools can
exchange best practices shared resources
and create more integrated and
supportive public education systems this
benefits all public school students
regardless of which type of school they
attend in conclusion by eliminating the
first right of refusal it limits access
to valuable public resources that should
be used to support public education for
all students and I urge you to oppose HB
719 and continue supporting policies
that prioritize
students um I just a couple notes um
just based on some of the things I heard
heard um there is one school that has
been able to take um advantage of this
bill since it has been enacted and
that's Compass classical in Northfield
um I did discuss it with them before
coming um they said it was a difficult
process um but they were able to get
through it um we do find that so far um
we call it um sick buildings a majority
of the time these buildings a lot of the
towns are moving on and building
buildings because they're not finding
that it's um it makes sense financially
to renovate these buildings so we
haven't found a lot of buildings that
have been helpful for Charter Schools um
but sometimes as in the compass
classical situation they found that they
just wanted a new school and they
decided that U they were going to sell
this building to that point um the
charter schools are not getting these
buildings for free they are actually
purchasing the buildings so this is a
sale a first threer refusal is just that
that it's saying hey you're the we're
giving you the first option to purchase
so it's not saying that nobody can
purchase it it's not saying that the
town is giving up money for this school
it's saying that they have the first
option to purchase the building um it's
not to say that a town doesn't have the
option also to work with a charter
school and say hey um because
maybe um for example there might be a a
charter school in Manchester where 90%
of those students are Manchester
students um so a Manchester might want
to work with that charter school and say
hey we're going to give you a discount
on that building because most of those
kids are Manchester kids so the
Manchester might want to work with them
and give them a discount on the building
um so there might be situations that
might occur like that and that does
happen in other states when I talk to
some of my other alliances that does
happen um so that is possibility down
the line so not to say that some towns
might want to give a building for free
or at a discount that's a possibility
and that's a negotiation that a town
might decide to do um and then as far as
um he gave several examples of schools
that weren't doing so well or with some
fraudulent activity obviously not great
situations um but I just want to point
out that any school that's actually
purchasing a building those are stable
schools that have been and um showing a
lot of sustainability and those are the
schools that are actually purchasing
buildings schools that have closed
schools that have
shown you know fraudulent not great
activity those schools aren't purchasing
buildings those are the schools that are
um leasing buildings and so the schools
that are looking to purchase those are
the stable schools that we're looking at
who are looking for long-term
stability I'm looking for questions
thank you very much you're welcome
represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us so would you
say that the local communities do have
the final word on what happens to those
buildings I would say so yeah I mean and
but like you said we haven't gotten too
far into it at this point but as so far
yes thank you representative worse if
this bill was to somehow pass then to my
understanding wouldn't it make it
extremely difficult for or Charter
Schools to be able to find suitable
buildings that they would be able to use
as schools instead of sitting in malls
or
shops um it is currently difficult now
um and it is still even with this bill
it is difficult um and like I said you
know a lot of the buildings are already
deemed to be not usable before they move
on um the
towns it depends what the towns decide
of why they're moving on to other
buildings and why they're leaving these
buildings
vacant um if they're choosing to leave
them vacant because they're not um
feasible to maintain financially then
it's definitely not going to work for a
charter school because they don't have
enough funds but if it's because they're
moving on for another reason and it's
financially feasible then that's great
um time will tell if this bill is going
to work for our Charter Schools but we
won't know unless we leave it on the
books thank you represent Murray um
thank you Mr chair thanks for maybe this
isn't a question for you it might be for
um the department is there a world in
which a district a public school
district leases their land from the town
and by any sort of set of circumstances
offering the building then as a first
right of refusal would also sort of cut
out the town's agency in the
process so the land itself
right yeah I I don't know how it I don't
know why a Char would on to get involved
with lease like leasing the land no I'm
not sure if I'm understand follow up
thank you my question is a district who
has an established school perhaps might
lease the town might lease the building
from the town it would already exist
there so is there any world in which
that occurs where then we would have to
be
offering you want a charter school to
lease the building from the town what I
am asking is does that have an impact to
how this piece of legislation is written
if the land is as a district the land is
leased oh from the
town that might be a better question for
the Department yeah that might not be
good question for
[Laughter]
me anything represent
Woodcock thank you for coming two
questions some point I thought you said
I may be wrong I thought you said that
there there's no funding for this
through currently does the charter
schools have a right to a $50,000 a year
either rental or lease or
payment there is lease
Aid no up to 50,000 a year off hand I I
don't know the numbers off I thought I
said you thought I thought I heard you
said they didn't and not everybody
qualifies for it either follow sh yes
thanks the second part was um is your
interpretation the same as the
representative presentative bill or
representative McDonald's in terms of
who has first lease
option the representative was saying the
child of schools has first least option
on unused Public School building I think
representative McDonald is inferring
that they really don't so from being the
alliance what's your position no I
believe what she was reading is that the
town H owns the building and they can
try to use it in any way they wish and
if they deem that they can't use it then
the before they decide to sell it then
the charter school has first RIT refusal
so if the town decides they want to use
it for some other purpose they can
because they own the building but if
they decide they're going to sell it
then they have to ask a charter school
first thank you that's how I interpret
wait till the department thank
you it any further questions for Miss
Adams see none thank you very much for
being here today thank you and we'll
call uh the department up um as there
seems to be a few questions maybe the
department could answer um I'm not sure
if uh two three four five want to come
[Music]
the so conveniently all three of us are
here um so because I think you're
touching on a lot of different subjects
and a lot of different topics
specifically around charter schools and
charter school facilities um a lot of
the things that you've asked questions
about today the department may not have
answers to because there are not
necessarily areas that we've dealt with
in the past um please remember that the
right of first refusal law is relatively
new we've had one school that's accessed
it and the department was um not really
involved in that process um as as um jod
Adam said before it was a process that
it was not necessarily easy but it did
end up working in the in the long run
um but all of these concepts are
relatively new um new legislation and so
the department has had either very
little role or very minimal um number of
opportunities to implement them so um I
guess with that um I don't we don't have
anything necessarily prepared or planned
to actually testify relev to this mostly
we're just here to take questions and
provide technical support okay I
actually have a question first um are
there funds available if there's a
building that's sick and a and a charter
school wants to purchase that are there
funds available for fixing it up so um a
kind of a couple different Avenues there
so Charter Schools um if they are a new
charter school and they have um they
would have to have already purchased the
building if they new charter school and
they would receive a federal Charter
School startup Grant they could use some
funds as long as is to deal with safety
requirements required by the state to
open um if it were an existing Charter
School charter schools are able to apply
for State Building Aid which is money
available to renovate school facilities
that again is new I think it passed last
year allowing schools to um access that
um and so the first year that charter
schools are able to submit building Aid
applications are this year there would
be due by April 1st we don't know if
Charter Schools will submit an
application once the charter school
submits an application it go it's the
application is ranked and placed on a
list and is building aid funds are made
available the Department of Education
funds representa Murray thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question the initial question I had
asked I think the prime sponsor or maybe
it was um was
around the list that is housed on the
department's website of available
buildings potentially that's how I'm
interpreting this
um does the district have any onus or
responsibility to reach out to Charter
Schools and say hey this is available
and how long does that window have to
stay I believe that's actually the
purpose of that list and why the
legislature wanted the department to
collect that information so Charter
Schools could access easily access that
information Statewide so when you all
require the department to do the unused
facility surve survey um and publish it
on our website that is now a resource
available to Charter Schools to see what
may be out there for inventory follow up
follow up and how long does
that opportunity have to State on the
department's website but let's say that
building sits on there for a year two
years and nobody comes forward and says
hey I have an interest in this at what
point can a a town or a district move
forward with trying to so I I the list
is a point in time collection um we
collect I think every other it's the
it's every other year it is every year
every year July yeah we post it in July
of each year um and so um the a so right
now it's February that list could be age
and schools could have moved on you know
selling a facility there's no
requirement for them to hold on to a
facility for a period of
time representative wock thank you m
chair good afternoon once again um just
go back I'm trying to I'm trying to get
the accurate
interpretation of this regulation um
as is it the Department's position and I
read it several times is the
Department's position that the first non
School use of that building unused
building then becomes the first option
for the um child school or is it the
position that the um the public can the
local school board can can use for
anything before the school TR the school
um I think we'll have to get back to you
on that question would you mind emailing
that more specifically so we can work
technology you can ask Jen to email it
to us surely I think we really need to
work with our attorney to clarify that
so I mean that may thank you that I mean
that's that's the essence of where where
the where the public school loses or I
think the represent of local control
where the public school loses that
authority to control the use of that
building so if the first option is
clearly after the public school done
with it then it goes to the Charter
School window that's one or no it
doesn't go to child window goes to
wherever they want it to go that's I
guess that's the question we're trying
to I'm trying to get so I think
typically wrer first refusal is relative
the school can list it for sale and when
they have offers the first refusal the
charter school they have to offer it to
the charter school first assuming that
the offer is of the appropriate cost um
and then the charter school has the
first right to refuse it and then it
goes to potentially other offers that
they would have on that property but I
believe the school can still list the
property for sale but the child of
school the charter school has the right
if they if they meet the appropriate
cost as First Option yes okay perfect
thank you representative celik thank you
and thank you for taking my question I I
saw you cut looking at each other when I
asked my question earlier but so I'm
just trying to understand if a building
such as the pre oyster ofer Middle
School is truly deemed as not usable and
they need to take down the building so
it's not that they're looking for a new
use would that is that impacted by this
law because they're not trying to reuse
the building they're just trying to rid
themselves of yeah I see they're not
selling it so this is right of person on
only related to salties for sales yes I
or or lease yes so in charter schools
have to follow facility standards as
well so then maybe that so we do the
similar to the um facility inspection
program that we have with District
Public Schools we have a similar
facility inspection um requirement for
charter schools so if something is
unusable by a public school it's also
likely unusable by a charter school
without substantial Renovations and so I
mean there are times that Charter School
a charter school potentially could
purchase something but then they would
be responsible for the renovations which
then that they would have to apply for
building Aid if they didn't have private
financing for that representative McDon
thank you madam chair and thank you once
again I think I have the same sort of
question and we seem to be interpreting
this a little bit differently so my
clarification is how would the
department interpret this where it says
um which the school district has no
school board approved ridden plan for
future use so couldn't theoretically the
school board say that they wanted to use
a building for housing or something else
and if the school board were to vote on
that does that count as a approved ring
plan and they could use it for something
else I I think that's something we' have
to clarify at the department um and
if you wanted to add Clarity to the law
you could do that as well okay thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair I I think um my question also is
around whether or not so let's say is
there a world I guess I'm asking you all
because you have that data where a
district leases the land and building
from a town and if a public school
district and so in the event that they
are done with the building or moving on
if that goes back to the town would that
somehow be in violation of this or would
that usurp the rights of the town to be
able to take their so I mean leases and
purchases are are separate items and so
I I don't think that they would impact
each other um and we have had Charter
Schools lease facilities from towns or
school districts before in the past so
follow if I sure so then would it be the
charter school reaching out to the town
if the public school district lease
expired and the town kept it
I think I'm confused by what trying ask
I guess what what I am asking is is
there a world in which a district
separate from the actual town is leasing
the physical land that the building is
oh okay I see yeah so I don't think that
it would impact this no I think it has
to be owned by the district to be
impacted by this thank you any other
and with that we'll close the hearing on
HB
719 we're going to go right
in
okay
e
okay we're going to open the hearing on
HB 730
8 requiring certain non-public schools
or education service providers that
accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers and I welcome the prime
sponsor representative luno thank you
very much Madam chair members of the uh
the committee for the record my name is
Dave luno and uh representing the people
of Mari County District nine which are
folks that live in who are folks that
live in hopkington and bo uh but I
always say like to you know I don't give
up conquered very quickly used to be in
my district and U and uh also uh
representing people all across the uh
beautiful Granite State because what
comes to this Committee just like this
bill affects all of us no matter where
you live so um so it's always great to
uh to hear um from you and to uh to join
you this afternoon and uh and I think
I'm the only thing between you and uh
and wherever you want to go next uh
today so so um I'm here to introduce
House Bill
738 which is titled requiring certain
non-public schools or education service
providers that accept public funds to
perform background checks on all
employees and volunteers um the first
thing I want to say about this bill
because we've you know it's a little bit
of a of a groundhog day this we've seen
this bill in here before and um um in uh
in the House Education committee we've
seen it before and uh and this bill as
uh as produced had the S had the same um
bug in it that uh that earlier versions
of this of this had so I passed a an
amendment out um just now and there's
extra copies right here on the on the
corner um and I worked with um with um
Amanda Weeden uh of the of you know who
who's a home education advocate on the
language in this and and the there is no
intention of this of this bill to put
any requirements on um on uh inhome
education you know parents and and uh
and and people like like that and and um
uh it is it is strictly about about
providing or requiring um criminal
background criminal history back checks
for um for people that are either
contracted by the Department of
Education or are employed as uh service
providers um or employed with service
providers or with um with non-public um
um uh schools and U and you know and I I
I don't really want to have to get into
all the reasons why criminal background
checks are so important I think a lot of
us have heard that before but um you
know for anybody that served on a school
board and I think there's probably
several of us um in the room today have
done that you know the health Safety and
Security of of our of our students of
our kids is the most important thing and
um and you know and it's heartbreaking
when we hear stories like we're in the
news today here even in here in New
Hampshire about um about events that
happen and um and and you know obviously
you don't know what quite is happening
when when you have to lock down a school
or go into a code red or or or whatever
it is but uh but you sure as hope it's
not going to be something that's going
to
jeopardize the health and safety and
security of um of you know our most
precious cargo so um so that's the
intention of uh of this bill is to
require criminal background checks who
for for um for employees and volunteers
who are working directly with students
in person not not you know not not
remotely not U not not by selling
materials or anything like that but are
providing in-person instruction to
students and I'd like to just sort of go
through the bill and um and talk quickly
about the amendment when we when we get
to uh that that part but but there's
basically I there's
five six sections to it but there's
really four parts to the bill and I'll
just I'll just run through it very
quickly um the the first part begins in
section one and it's basically talking
about how criminal background checks
this is a new section would U would be
required for any employee or volunteer
of an entity contracted for Educational
Services by the department but so by the
New Hampshire Department of Education or
by the state board so these are um these
are um you know people who are working
directly with students in person with
students um so it's got the word
inperson instruction you can see that on
line five um and this will be a common
theme that we're going to see as we go
we go through this that uh that if
they're providing inperson instruction
under contract for the Department of
Education then they need to have a
criminal pass a criminal back history
background check um the second part is
actually section two another new
paragraph and this refers to the
education tax credit program and um and
uh it uh leads in on lines 9 and 10 all
employees and volunteers of non-public
schools or providers that choose to
accept scholarship students under this
chapter and provide access um uh oh
sorry to the results criminal history
background check so so this this is
making sure that that educational that
sorry that providers under the education
tax credit program are um are compliant
with criminal background checks um Mo
and this is where where some I I think
uh some language as an artifact in an
earlier version of this came into play
Miss Miss Weeden actually uh picked up
on this and said look I thought you
weren't going to be impacting home
education and no there's no intent to
impact home education here so so it
remedies a um um an a uh some language
that's on 15 by striking the word home
or home education or home education
program sorry it strikes out those four
words and that's the um that's what you
see in the the amendment um uh
0124 so uh so we get rid of the uh the
reference to home education program um
from from that uh paragraph the uh the
third piece it does is talks about
alternative programs and again we're
talking about employees and volunteers
um and such Alterna of program so now
I'm sort of down at lines 23 and 24 who
provide in-person instruction so there's
that term again uh alternative programs
are also commonly known as learn
everywhere uh around the state so so
these programs can vary from a um oh jez
a u
uh uh you know working work working for
a um for or interning at a company like
like ba systems in jhua and um uh and uh
and yeah if you're if if you've got a
supervisor there or somebody that you're
working with there that's um that's as
part of the learn everywhere program
yeah they're going to have to pass a
criminal history background check they
may already have passed that if they're
working for BA systems because a lot of
these people I think have security
clearances anyway I know some of my uh
Sun friends who who work there all do so
uh so they may have already gone through
um through that but if you're going to
be in front of students
um using programs that are um that are
that are that are essentially organized
through through the state providing
inperson instruction uh criminal
background uh check is um that's the uh
the the name of the game and the fourth
part here and this um this is down at
the bottom of page one and the top of
page two uh talks about the EFA program
and so again it's um it's uh submitting
the results of criminal history record
check with complies with the
requirements blah blah blah for any
employee or volunteer providing here's
the term instruction in person uh uh to
a uh to an EFA student so we're not
talking about um you know buying buying
books from Amazon or or um you know or
other materials that are um that are
that are uh that are uh eligible
expenses that you know as part of the
the state's Voucher Program we're
talking about in-person instruction here
uh I think it's a complete bill I think
it it it closes the um the the the Hole
uh so to speak where um where criminal
history records checks are not being uh
provided uh for inperson instruction
when when State funds or state contracts
are involved so I think it uh hopefully
can can put this issue to rest at least
for now and uh and I hope uh the
committee looks looks favorably on um
protecting the health Safety and
Security of uh all our kids thank you
thank you um I just have a quick
question about the education tax credit
money that money does not go into the
education trust fund correct uh that's
my understanding is it does not but I uh
so you're still considering that to be
it's state M State money
yeah okay representative celik thank you
so much and thank you for taking my
question just to clarify you referen
like someone going to work for Bae so if
my daughter were doing her Extended
Learning opportunity at Bae with their
marketing department it would be the
person she's directly working with who'd
be subject to this not every single
employee in the company that would be my
make sure I understand my interpretation
that and and the goal is to just make
sure that people who are teaching in
small circumstances are not uh
perpetrators of violence against correct
correct thank representing McDonald
thank you madam chair and high
representative um just seeing this
amendment for the first time um provided
the amendment is not approved the bill
is
introduced would this bill require
parents to pass background check and if
so where would you draw the line on
government overreach to educate their
own children if hom school is the
ultimate form of local control so thank
you very much representative McDonald
for the question I um if the Amendments
not approved I I sort of doubt the bill
would would be U recommended ought to
pass but but there there's absolutely no
intention to do criminal background
check on um on on parents um so I I I
draw the line right where I I think
you're probably Drawing the Line parents
are not subject to criminal background
check when home educating their their
their kids may I have a followup follow
sure so you say that's your stated
intention with the amendment and I would
understand that but the the bill if the
amendment were not to pass you would say
should not or would not pass or is the
amendment critical to this and it's
detrimental if it's not included yeah so
um so I I I think from a policy
perspective if the amendment were not
were to fail this committee I suspect
the bill would also be recom we not be
recommended out to pass so I don't
really see that as a as a as a as a as a
likelihood that you would you would um
you know I obviously I don't want I'm
not on I don't serve on this this
committee but I see it as a very
unlikely possibility that the committee
would would vote down the amendment and
vote up the uh the bill so uh you know
are you suggesting that for whatever
reason if the amendment were not to pass
we should vote down this bill that's
simply what I'm asking uh I'm not
suggesting what you guys should do I'm
just suggesting what what I think a ly
outcome would be okay thank
you representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative luno for coming in
front of us so I just have a quick
question there's a fiscal note on this
and my concern would be who's paying for
these background checks at $25 a pop
yeah so so so these are all you know
through through you know people being
contracted with the state providing
Services under contract for the state
providing inperson instruction through
programs that are that are offered
through the state so the idea is that
the state would be the um the the payer
of the um the criminal background checks
but um uh how much did you say
$25 um you know I would want to know if
I was a parent that and the state was
offering educ in-person educational
instructional services to my child that
the state would at least invest $25 to
make sure that they wouldn't weren't
putting some with a criminal background
in front of my kid thank you represent
Morse hi yes thank you for taking my
question as well for the question here
um it almost seems like the amendment
may actually be in contradiction to the
bill itself so just help me
clarify with EFA students some of which
use the EA funds for homeschooling with
their parents in
essence using the funds it says to
remove or home education does that also
eliminate the education Freedom accounts
or is that just step right because I'm
worried about the contradic no that's a
that's a good question I don't see the
contradiction in there if you see one
that may be something that that the
committee may want to explore uh some
more it's your bill and um and and you
know I'm not trying to make um your jobs
uh uh any harder than they already are
but uh but if there's if there's if
there's a problem there then then I'd be
happy to work with any members of this
committee to to help resolve that I I
hope we can all agree that Health Safety
and Security of um of our kids is a is a
top priority but um but if so if there's
if there's if there's a contradiction if
there's a problem let's let's try to
solve it representative
dry thank you um Madam chairman thank
you for taking my question I I just want
to build on that when home Home
Educators take EFA funds they no longer
are called Home Educators they are EFA
students so
let's go to um the last page which is D
where you talk about education providers
not I'm not talking about the parents
but I'm talking about anybody else who
works with your student if you are
educating at home and receiving
education Freedom account funds you are
no longer Home
Educators but there are people that are
interacting in person with your
child this says that any employee or
volunteer providing instruction in
person to an EA student which your
students are would have to do a
background check is that what you're
talking about would they have to do that
I think that's that's if if you're
you're compensating those those people
through EFA fund so they're basically
being paid through is it called class
wallet from the children scholarship um
uh fund um if if you're using your EFA
funds to to to to um yes to pay for
services then I think they would they
would have to uh be uh be have to have
provided have to gone through a criminal
background check but but EFA funds I
mean let's let's be let's be honest are
we only going to go so far so so I I
mean I think a I think a common thing
we've heard about what about the piano
teacher from from next door or or my my
my aunt uh comes over and and teaches my
son uh piano well if if they're doing
that and not not doing that through the
the education Freedom account program
then no I don't see them being subject
to a background check but if you're
Contracting with a um with a with a with
a piano teacher that um that's providing
these services and you're paying that
that piano teacher through uh through
voucher funds then yeah they they should
have um they they should have completed
a criminal background check and I'll go
a step further and say that that if um
you know we're not we're now not talking
about a relative or the person next door
we're talking about somebody who who may
be a professional um you know piano
teacher and um and and I maybe at at
that point it's very likely that they
have um actually undergone a criminal
background check you know a lot of
people um I think would would have their
minds put at ease if uh if somebody's
coming over uh into their home um during
maybe part of the time of the day when
when there's no other uh no other adults
at home uh to to have have you know been
at least you know U passed a criminal
history background check follow up
follow up thank you um I'm just looking
at it it says any employee or volunteer
providing instruction so that says to me
that they're not being paid but if
they're even if they are
volunteers a a person a private person
private citizen cannot ask for a uh
backround check on another private
citizen How would they go about doing it
I think they'd go through the Department
of Education on that so and and if it's
a volunteer maybe there are
volunteers you know along with um with
you know some some service that's being
contracted for it may have a volunteer
working for them so I'm just just you
know leaving the door open to make sure
that anybody that's whether they're a um
a paid person or volunteer um through a
a a service provider that is being paid
for through the education Freedom
account program if they're providing if
they're they're if they're in person
with um with with the student then then
yeah this bill is having him um go
through a criminal background check
represent
wck good afternoon representative um Uno
the question I have just f up on
representative dr's question if I recall
and I'm probably wrong you're old on you
might remember this better volunteers
and Volunteers in public school who come
on a regular basis they aren't they
required the same background check as
pay feature I think they are I think
they are volunteers but yeah okay yeah
thank you thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you you've been very generous
ring thank you madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Steven King
I represent uh Hillsboro 18 in
Manchester uh bear with me I got a
little bit of a cold or not so much a
cold but like allergies going on today
um so I want to kind of go over this it
changed my mind of what I was going to
say I kind of threw that idea out of the
window after I heard everybody's
questions um and actually on the back
where uh he just left off at it says
submit results uh criminal background
history with a volunteer there um so to
look at this perspective he did say that
it should be anybody that's receiving
funds it doesn't say that in the bill
and actually the amendment actually
changes it to the fact that it makes
more confusing light of it um but I
would say that that volunteer there
providing instruction any person in EFA
student so like you did say the EFA
student is anybody receiving those funds
so now again he did mention that like my
father-in who teaches my daughter
accordion would now have to go through a
background check if my mother-in-law
decided to teach her math they would
have to according to this bill we can
say all day long that there is an issue
with the way the wording is but it
doesn't say collecting funds through
class wallet it doesn't say anything
specific and again according to
Department of Labor they have no purview
over that if you not labor sorry
Department of Education uh again that's
something the department probably be
able to shed more light on for you um
but again the word volunteers mentioned
several times in the bill which would
also qualify for those people so again I
I just looking at this I mean it's been
obviously a transition from the last
bill a little bit uh that came through
last time but I would encourage you guys
to itl this bill by if you have any
question any questions seeing none thank
thank you madam chair honorable
committee for record representative
Henry gon Hillsboro 29th
District so part of the reason that we
do background checks in public education
is because we are trying to protect kids
when they are not in the cust uh custody
of their Prime custodian their parents
usually
the other part of the reason is to try
to absolve liability on the state when
an instance like we heard about the
other day happens so that the state can
say we under good authority did
background checks in order to try to do
the best that we could now obviously no
system is perfect and somebody slips
through the cracks but we can honestly
say that as a state we did the best that
we could to protect children while they
were in our
charge having this bill apply to
homeschool networks and to private
education accounts does not meet two of
those standards both of those standards
one of them is the parents are directly
involved whereas at a private school or
a public school the parents are not at
school the parents are directly involved
in the selection process in a homeschool
Network or in Freedom account situation
they are never not the custodian of the
child or the protector of the child so
you know and and there is no State
liability so we're asking the state to
spend money in a place where there is no
State liability where there is liability
in the public education system or even
in a private education system that's
licensed through the state so this
doesn't meet either criteria that makes
it good legislation in addition to the
fact that it's written in a very
ambiguous way that would be very hard to
enforce or or uh or judicially interpret
so thank you for your time thank you
representative
selig thank you so um forgive me I'm not
familiar with which incident happened
the other day but um the bill references
non-public schools which to my
understanding would include private
schools parochial schools and other
small or large Independent Schools of of
whatever
size in addition separate from The
Homeschool component but just it
references those schools specifically do
is it your belief that the people who
work at those schools should not be
subject to background checks
because uh is that not sorry I was
asking that y the person testifying not
the committee thank you is that not
already the
policy I don't know that it's a
guaranteed policy at all schools so
should we not make sure that that's the
policy at all schools unless there's an
issue where the state is liable or where
we see an issue that needs to be
addressed no I don't think it's the
perview of the state to reach into
private
entities representative wock than you m
chair good afternoon thank you for
sticking around thank you um you talked
about the the your concern the I it was
a h school network that those youngsters
enrolled at are selected by the parent
to go there and I just want to
differentiate that the if I'm clear the
parent May select uh Network a to send
my child of a home school to this young
lady who's teaching a home school
network but when they go to that hom
school program correct uh your parents
not with them all the time the parents
not the oversight the guardian at that
time and I think the bill was trying to
get to the point that if if whoever I
hire uh to teach my children if they're
home school or whatever is or how you
whichever category you want to put them
in you're not there as the parent is the
guardian so this document this criminal
background check is an assurance to
those parents even though I mean they
pick out a public school to go and the
public schools checked all the people
they're not sure about all the people
but that's Public School done due
diligence the same thing here the
background check is a standard for due
diligence that you can feel comfortable
with that this lady who's teaching uh
OBO is is um at least has a background
check you may have selected her because
that's what you wanted to teach or you
know she's a teacher of that was my
confusion question you have a question
yeah was because he said that the
parental the parent custody of the child
he said the parents and custody of the
child trying to make a point that they
weren't in Cody the child I don't think
because they leave ated entity that that
was that's I trying to clarify from your
testimony now respectfully sir I have no
idea what your question is I'm sorry the
question is do you believe that you said
that the parent custody of the child is
theirs and you were concerned about
State liability and I was suggesting to
you once even even in homeschool bound
programs as you said when they go to a
provider from even the home you selected
that person that person is you the
parents not there so that's what they
that's why the background check would be
requested that's that was the you seem
to insinuate the parent would be there
because they selected the person the
parent's not in custody of that child
the teacher is there with a child 101
think that was my question versus your
statement that's all if it's confusing
I'll let it go they don't answer I'm
asking you if it's confusing to you or
to me I won't do it I won't ask it
that's fine I just don't know what the
question is I didn't insinuate anything
I I I stated very clearly that the
reason that we do background checks for
public schools is to absolve liability
and to protect children so
representative Murray thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
one of the questions that I had I think
you mentioned public oversight but there
is a public taxpayer accountability
component to this through the EFA wallet
so my question was would language that
was would there be more amendable
language to something like a third-party
doe approved provider who is providing
services within these programs outside
of I understood the questions about um
home educator or a parent homeschooling
that I understand would there be more
amenable language that you could support
to ensure that thirdparty outside
entities who are approved for
reimbursement Services through the
department of Ed were having these
background checks
done representative thank you for the
question I would have to see that bill
but that is not this bill initially my
reaction would be to favor against it
just because again it it takes on uh it
shifts live ility to the state is now an
entity that's responsible for doing
these background checks which can slow
down the process for private um for
private interactions but that's not this
bill representative
Lichfield thank you madam chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question so I just want to ask you that
since right now we're talking about
State funds and we're talking about
background checks because State funds
are involved if we have a parent that is
accepting Medicaid Aid or Medicare if
they're disabled but they're accepting
some type of payment from the state and
they're looking to hire a babysitter
should we do a background check on that
babysitter since they are receiving
State
funds thank you for the question rep uh
representative again I would say that's
that's not this bill but if I saw that
bill in front of me I would I would lean
toward favoring against it as an
overreach into somebody's Private
Affairs representative Morris thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question so I have a very right over
here
sorry very very very simple question
that's probably going to be the easiest
that you're going to get
um no matter what laws regulations or
anything you put in place is it true
that criminals will just be criminals
and they'll break them if they decide
to honorable has been representative yes
sir that's true um I mean I I I'm a
proud veteran of the United States Army
24-year Career and I would submit to you
that we have one of the best background
check systems in place place with
security clearances Etc and sometimes a
bad player gets through um you know to
be to be an educator you have to go
through one of these background checks
and for anybody that didn't get the news
there's there's somebody accused of
improprieties with children in one of
our school districts uh here within the
past week I would suggest that again the
state did everything it prudently could
do to absolve liability for suit against
the state or Department of Education but
sometimes Bad actors get through and
also sometimes people change um people
have have experiences that change them
and not always for the better so
unfortunately no matter how much we try
to legislate from here there are going
to be bad actors that get through and
that's one of the reasons that I remind
this body that as legislators we don't
make polite suggestions we make laws
that are backed by people with with guns
and that will will commit fines and
penalties against the people so if you
are not completely confident our first
duty is to protect the rights of the
people and if the government isn't a
victim here then the government has no
role in getting into the rights of the
people any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
Markle hi thank you for listening to me
my name is Louise Martell and I live in
Berlin New Hampshire and my husband and
I homeschool are two adopted children
and we are
unfunded and so we don't really belong
in this group we're not receiving funds
from the state in any way we don't
receive medicare from the state we don't
do anything with the state this is
something that we chose for our children
because they respond really well to
homeschooling I'm not entirely opposed
to background checks when they're
necessary I've been through many
background checks I was a CA I adopted
children I worked for the church I've
had background checks but I find this to
be an
overreach and the bill is poorly written
it includes people that should not be
included in this group it's negligent
defining who is directed to assigning
background
checks which educational pathway will it
affect the EFA or the
193a they're two different pathways
even though they might call themselves
homeschooling it's a different pathway
and there's different regulations when
you're receiving funds from the state
there are certain things that you have
you expect but when you're not expected
get getting the money from the state
then stay out of my business you know
it's it's as simple as that I love my
children home education families choose
the pathways appropriate for their
families this bill does not
differentiate the pathways public
schools have fewer restrictions I've
been asked to volunteer at public school
and they didn't know I had a background
check or not my husband works for the
public school in our area he's a coach
you know he has been
vetted
um I just find this bill does not State
who is to pay for all these background
checks who is to administer and enforce
them who will pay for the bureaucratic
nightmare that I see happening I see it
as an overreach because it I don't think
it's going to stop here I don't think
it's going to just stop with EFA or even
with homeschool Fe families I think it's
going to be expected from all families
and families have a right to their
privacy you know not all families are
bad not all families are good but there
are other ways of determining these
things without invasion of
privacy um this place is an undue
Financial constraint on many 193a home
education families and uh I I consider
this government overreach power
excellence and intrusion on every
parents right to direct their children's
education and Welfare so
I don't think parents should be
subjected to criminal background checks
like I said I see it as a bureaucratic
nightmare thank you representative
Hall chair thank you for taking my
question would you say the amendment
does stay out of your business the
amendment no it does not say stay out of
my business it's in my business I'm a
homeschool Mom it doesn't exclude us
from background checks and I work with
other families who do receive EFA we
have a co-op I teach at this EFA I mean
at be a co-op and I'm not being I'm not
being paid I'm a volunteer it would mean
that I would have to have a background
check because they're EFA parents there
it does not you know it's like why would
I have to pay for a background check or
even have a background check when it
doesn't even it's not I'm there I'm
there with my
kids I'm doing the homes school thing so
my kids they do not go off on their
own you know maybe I'm not trust in I
get it but they need me and so I'm there
for
you I gave
thank you for your time committee
members my name is Diane Nolan from
Windam New Hampshire I began educating
my children onto RSA 193a over 20 years
ago it is my opinion that all children
should be protected but this bill is not
the means to achieve that result and I
ask you to vote itl on it this is the
third attempt to introduce a criminal
background check bill on Home
Educators last session we listened to
three hours of testimony and link the
executive session filled with expert
Witnesses for HB 628 the previous
iteration of today's bill it was clear
that HB 628 created more problems than
it solved just as HB 738 would this
bill's target has not
changed today you'll hear plenty of
testimony about the right to privacy
government overreach and parental rights
but I ask you the following if we know
through the hearings on HB
628 that expert Witnesses testified on
the existing procedures for criminal
background checks the type the depth and
the many kinds that can be used and if
we know that criminal background checks
are already being used in the non-public
schools the dases of Manchester prena
and the EFA through testimony and
documentation that was clearly presented
during that
session and if we know that h B 738 does
not address the administrative aspects
of this proposal it does not address
What entity would administer this it
does not address who orders receives or
views these background checks or who
Bears the expense of these checks or how
much this will cost the state then we
have to question the motivation for
revisiting a bill that has failed twice
already and returns without
revisions it is false to say that this
bill does not impact Home Educators We
join in co-ops and many other group
learning opportunities with Etc
recipients and EFA
recipients and just one point of fact
the ETC money is business
donations thank you thank you very much
any
Thomas
Schmidt Madam chair honorable members of
the education policy and administration
committee thank you for for taking uh my
testimony my name is uh T.J Schmidt I'm
attorney with the homeschool legal
defense Association and we represent uh
hundreds of families all across the
state of New Hampshire in addition to
that I have the privilege of uh being
born here in in this great state I grew
up less than 40 miles from here in the
center of the universe up B New
Hampshire um I was also homeschooled and
my parents homeschooled my siblings here
in New Hampshire for many
years I would respectfully like to add
my voice to those who uh speak in Oppo
opposition to House Bill
738 House Bill 738 would unnecessarily
burden many homeschooling parents
homeschool co-ops with additional costs
regulation red tap red tape by
subjecting them to Ed criminal
background checks simply for educating
their children and participating in
homeschool groups providing Educational
Services to their own children even if
that homeschool family did not accept
public funds they would be required to
obtain criminal background checks simply
for volunteering at that homeschooling
Co-op that does accept students who have
received those public
funds to speak about the amendment uh it
only addresses one section that speaks
there as we've already been mentioned
here two other sections of this bill
would would also capture these
homeschool students so even if that
Amendment were to pass uh we would still
be in opposition to this bill New
Hampshire already has some very strong
laws to protect children it imposes
strong severe penalties on those who
harm children as a previously
homeschooled student and as a
homeschooled father myself I can speak
from my own personal experience most
homeschool co-ops have a comprehensive
polic and procedures to protect their
children most parents are present when
their children are being educated I
myself am a homeschool teacher at our
local home school co-op in my home state
where I currently live with my family as
parents we want our children to be safe
we're actively involved in monitoring
who teaches our
children House Bill 738 assumes that
parents can't be trusted to protect
their own children by mandating that
that Homeschool Group that they
participate in must require criminal
background checks even from those who
volun
here with all respect to this committee
and to its members requiring parents to
obtain that criminal background checks
to Volunteers in a group educational
activity is insulting it certainly
doesn't live up to our M motto to live
free please oppose house spell
738 thank you very much any questions
representative B Bon thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um you mentioned that
homeschool cooperatives do have
procedures in place uh to ensure that
your children are safe I was just
wondering because I I'm not aware of
those and I'm just curious if you could
share some of those with us well I can
only speak from my own personal
experience and thank you for your
question um I I would say for the co-op
that I've participated in and the ones
that you know that I'm currently
participating in we have a requirement
that any teacher who's teaching a child
have someone else there present and
another adult that no parent uh and our
Co-op requires parents to participate in
teaching if their child goes to the
co-op they're required to participate uh
and if they're not able to be there they
have to make allowance for that so in in
the co-op that I currently participate
in at least two adults must be present
whenever children no children is allowed
to be alone with an adult who's teaching
we also have other policies and
requirements I know some policies
require background checks uh but in each
homeschool Co-op that I've participated
over the years we as parents have been
responsible for ensuring the safety of
our
children thank you for sharing
that repres McDonald thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here and
for your testimony you stated that you
were against the bill and against the
amendment is there any Amendment you
could see to this to approve it or is
this bill Beyond repair it's not
salvageable thank you for your question
in my opinion uh this bill needs to fail
and that there's nothing that could be
done thank
you representative celik thank you just
for claric ification um you talked about
having grown up in eping and working for
this organization do you currently live
in New Hampshire or are you just here at
the beesan organization yeah thank you
for your question I currently
unfortunately do not live in New
Hampshire uh I live in West Virginia and
uh my wife is from Florida and about as
far north as I could get her to come
with was West Virginia so no I do not
currently live in New Hampshire
unfortunately but I do have many
relatives extended family who live here
so so you're testifying on behalf of I'm
testifying on behalf of the homeschool
legal defense association yes mhm any
other questions seeing none thank you
roacher thank you madam chair my name is
Michelle roacher and I am a 193a home
educator in the state of New Hampshire
my family lives in barington and and the
um education tax credit scholarship is
something that my family participates in
this bill itself ropes my family in when
I accept the education tax credit
scholarship I do not compromise my 193a
status making an amendment that does not
eliminate the tax credit scholarship
still leaves homeschoolers as defined by
193a
this bill would directly affect me in
any
instances even if I wasn't a home
educator if I was a
volunteer in a homeschool Co-op I've
participated in co-ops in the past where
we've had people come in and teach
something we didn't pay them to teach
they came and taught out of their base
of
knowledge as um Mr Schmidt already said
the co-ops that I've participated in
it's the parents that are leading it
it's the parents that are there um
and everything that I've ever done has
fallen under that we call it to deep
leadership where there are two adults in
the room unrelated so it can't be
anything um where it's uh questioned as
to whether or not something did happen
or didn't
happen
the responsibility to make sure my
children are
safe is
mine I don't need the state to be
involved in that
process this
bill requires me to involve the state in
that
process I've personally passed several
criminal background checks for different
organizations that I have to volunteer
in or that I choose to volunteer in that
require the background
check I choose to participate in those
organizations and I choose to submit to
a criminal background
check this eliminates the
choice for anyone and as our already has
been stated and as I've stated at the
other iterations of this bill that have
been
submitted the fiscal note is
enormous thank you any
good afternoon and thank you for your
time today my name is Joseph pelli I'm a
uh homeschooling father of two boys live
in Dover um we fall under the 183a
statute um I came here today to express
my opposition to this
bill um I like to Echo a lot of the
concerns that have already been brought
up in opposition to this bill um but I
won't to sayfe time I won't reiterate
all these very valid concerns um I hope
they came through clear to
you
um so I came here to ask that you vote I
on this bill and upon arrival I learned
there was an amendment to try to address
some of the concerns of homeschool
families unfortunately I haven't read
this amendment but uh upon hearing the
responses of Representative Leno to a
lot of the questions from this committee
I realized that um it's still fall short
of addressing our
concerns
and um
excuse me a
minute uh still exposes us to a lot of
the uh overreach that we are concerned
about um as homeschool families in our
family's educational
choices um so I just like to ask you to
vote it on this bill even with the
amendment if it were to pass as it is
unnecessary for what we're trying to do
here thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much
is there anyone else who would like to
speak on this
bill seeing none we'll close the hear
e